[Music]
I'm really looking forward to this
lecture not like I wasn't looking
forward to the other ones but the
stories that I want to cover tonight one
of the things that just absolutely
staggers me about them especially the
story of Cain and Abel which I hope to
get to is like it's so short it's
unbelievable it's like ten eleven lines
there's nothing to it at all and I've
found that it's essentially
inexhaustible in its capacity to reveal
meaning and I don't exactly know what to
make of that I mean I do I think you
know because I said I was going to take
as rational an approach to this issue as
I possibly could I think it has
something to do with this intense
process of condensation across very long
periods of time that's the simplest
explanation but I'll tell you the
information in there is so densely
packed that it really is it's really
it's not that easy to come up with an
explanation for that not one that's that
I find fully compelling I mean I do
think that the really old stories and
we've been covering the really archaic
stories in the Bible so far I think that
one of the things that you can be
virtually certain about is that
everything about them that was memorable
was remembered right and so in some
sense and this is kind of like the idea
of Richard Dawkins ideas of memes which
is often why I thought that Richard
Dawkins feels a little bit more
mystically inclined he would have become
Karl you because there are theories are
unbelievably similar the similar of meme
and the similar of Arc the idea of
archetypes of the collective unconscious
are very very similar ideas except Union
ideas far more profound in my estimation
well it just is he thought it through so
much better you know because Dawkins
tended to think of Mimas sort of like a
mind worm you know something that would
infest a mind and maybe multiple minds
but he never really took I don't think
he really ever took the idea with the
seriousness it deserved and I did hear
him actually make a joke with Sam Harris
the last time they talked about the fact
that that there was some possibility
that the production of memes say
religious memes could alter evolutionary
history and they both avoided that topic
instantly they had a big laugh about it
men decided they weren't going to go
down that road and so that wasn't fair
that was quite interesting to me but
these
is the the the density of these stories
I do really think still is a is a
mystery
it certainly has something to do with
their absolute their in their
impossibility to be forgotten you know
and that's actually something that we
could be tested empirically I don't know
if anybody has ever done that because
you could tell naive people two stories
even equal length right one that had an
archetypal theme and the other that
didn't and then wait three months and
see which one's people remembered better
and be relatively straightforward thing
to test I haven't tested it but maybe I
will at some point but anyways that's
all to say that I'm very excited about
this lecture because I get an
opportunity to go over the story of Adam
and Eve and the story of Cain and Abel
and I hopefully manage both of those
today and maybe we'll get to the story
of Noah and the Tower of Babel as well
but I wouldn't count on it not Arthur
eight we've been not at the rate we've
been progressing if that's okay that's
that's no problem it's there's no sense
rushing this alright so we're going to
go before we go that before we do that I
want to finish my discussion of the idea
of the psychological significance of the
idea of God and I've been thinking about
this a lot more you know because of
course this lecture series gives me the
opportunity and the necessity to
continue to think and you know it
certainly is the case so the hypothesis
that I've been developing with the
Trinitarian idea is something like that
the Trinitarian idea is the earliest
emergence in image of the idea that
there has to be an underlying cognitive
structure that gives rise to
consciousness as well as consciousness
itself and so what I would suggest was
that the idea of God the Father is
something akin to the idea of the a
priori
structure that that gives rise to
consciousness you know that's an inbuilt
part of us so that's our structure you
could think about that as something
that's been produced over a vast
evolutionary time span and I don't think
that's completely out of keeping with
the with the with the ideas that are
laid forth in Genesis one at least if
you think about them from a metaphorical
perspective and it's hard to read them
literally because I don't know what you
know there's an emphasis on day and
night but the idea of day and night as
as 24-hour diurnal you know daytime and
nighttime interchanges that are based on
the claw
on the earthly clock seems to be a bit
absurd when you first start to think
about the construction of the cosmos so
just doesn't seem to me that a literal
interpretation is appropriate and I mean
it's another thing that you might not
know but you know many of the early
church fathers one of them Origen in
particular stated very clearly this was
in 300 AD that these ancient stories
were to be taken as as wise metaphors
and not to be taken literally like the
idea that the people who established
Christianity for example were all the
sorts of people who were biblical
literalist it's just absolutely
historically wrong I mean some of them
were and some of them still are that's
not the point many of them weren't and
it's not like people who live 2,000
years ago were stupid by any stretch of
the imagination and so they were
perfectly capable of understanding what
constant you know what constituted
something approximating a metaphor and
also knew that fiction in some sense
considered as an abstraction could tell
you truth that nonfiction wasn't able
wasn't able to get at lets you think
that fiction is only for entertainment
and I think that's a very that's a
that's a big mistake to think that so
alright so here we go so yes so with
regards to the idea of God the Father so
the idea is that in order to make sense
out of the world you have to have an a
priori cognitive structure that was
something that Immanuel Kant as I said
last time put forward as an argument
against the idea that all of the
information that we acquire during our
lifetime is a consequence of incoming
sense data and the reason that Kant
objected to that and he was absolutely
right about this is that you can't make
sense of sense data without an a priori
structure you can't extract from sense
data the structure that enables you to
make sense of sense data it's not
possible and that's really being
demonstrated I would say beyond the
shadow of a doubt since the 1960s and
the best demonstration of that was
actually the initial failure of
artificial intelligence because when the
AI people started promising that we
would have fully functional and
autonomous robots and artificial
intelligence back in the 1960s what they
didn't understand and what stole them
terribly until about the early 1990s was
that it was almost that the problem of
perception with a much deeper problem
than anybody ever recognized because
like when you look at the world you just
see well look there's objects out there
and by the way you don't
objects you see tools just so you know
in the neurobiology that's quite clear
you don't see objects and infer utility
you see useful things and infer object
so it's actually the reverse of what
people generally think but the point is
is that regardless of whether you see
objects or useful things when you look
at the world you just see it and you
think well seeing is easy because
they're the things are and all you have
to do is like you know turn your head
and they appear and that's just so wrong
that it's it's almost impossible to
overstate like the problem of perception
is staggeringly difficult and one of the
primary reasons that we still don't
really have autonomous robots so there
were a lot closer to it than we were in
the 1960s because it turned out that you
actually have to have an embodied you
have to have a body before you can say
it and even more importantly you have to
have a body before you can see because
the act of seeing is actually the act of
mapping the patterns of the world onto
the patterns of the body it's not things
are out there you see them then you
think about them then you evaluate them
then you decide to act on them and then
you act I mean that you could call that
a folk idea of psychological processing
or a perception it's not that is not how
it works like your eyes for example map
one of the things they do is map right
onto your spinal cord for example they
might right onto your emotional system
so it's actually possible for example
for people to be blind and still be able
to detect facial expressions which is to
say you can with someone who's
cortically blind so they've had their
visual cortex destroyed often by a
stroke they'll tell you that they can't
see anything but they can guess which
hand you put up if you ask them to and
if you flash them pictures of angry or
fearful faces they show skin conductance
responses to the more emotion laden
faces and it's because imagine that the
world is made out of patterns which it
is then imagine that those patterns are
transmitted to you electromagnetically
you have to light and then imagine that
the pattern is duplicated on the retina
and then that pattern is propagated
along the optic nerve and then the
pattern is distributed throughout your
brain and some of that pattern makes up
what you call conscious vision but other
parts of it just activate your body so
for example when I look at this when I
look at this this whatever it whatever
it is a bottle that's words
huh you know when I look at it
especially with intent in mind as soon
as I look at it the pattern of the BOD
of the bottle activates the gripping
mechanism of my hand and part of the
action of per sortie the active
perception is to adjust my bodily
posture including my hand grip to be of
the optimal size to pick that up and
it's not that I see the bottle and then
think about how to move my hand that's
too slow it's that I use my motor motor
cortex to perceive the bottle and that's
actually somewhat independent of
actually seeing the bottle as a
conscious experience so anyways huh the
reason the reason that I'm telling you
that all of that and there's much more
about that that can be told rodney
brooks 'is someone to know about he's a
robotics engineer who worked in the
1990s and he invented the Roomba among
many other things so he's a real genius
stuffed guy and he works was one of the
first people to really point out that to
have to be able to have a machine that
perceived well enough to work in the
world that you had to give it a body and
that the perception would actually be
built from the body up rather than from
the abstract cognitive perceptions down
and so well and that that turned out to
be the case and bird rooks boiled all
sorts of weird little machines in the
1990s that didn't even really have any
central brain but they could do things
like run away from light and so they
could perceive light that their
perception was that act of running away
from right and so perception perception
is very very very tightly tied to action
in ways that people don't normally
perceive anyways that's all to say that
you cannot perceive the world without
being embody and you know your embodied
in a manner that's taken you roughly
three and a half billion years to pull
off right there's being a lot of death
as a prerequisite to the embodied form
that you take and so it's taken all that
trial and error to produce something
like you that can interact with the
complexity of the world well enough to
last the relatively paltry 80 or so
years that you can last and so I think
about that as this may be wrong but I
think it's a useful at least it's a
useful hypothesis I think the idea
God the Father is something like the
birth of the idea that there has to be
an internal structure that out of which
consciousness itself arises that gives
form to things and well and if that's
the case and perhaps it's not but if
it's the case it's certainly reflection
it's a reflection of the kind of factual
truth that I've been describing now and
then like I also mentioned that I kind
of see the idea of both the Holy Spirit
and those also of Christ and most
specifically of Christ in in the form of
the word as the active consciousness
that that structure produces and uses
not only to to formulate the world
because we formulate the world at least
the world that we experience we
formulate but also to change and modify
that world because there's absolutely no
doubt that we do that partly with our
bodies which are optimally developed to
do that which is why we have hands
unlike dolphins would have you know very
large brains like us but can't really
change the world we're really adapted
and evolved to change the world and to
world and our speech is really a an
extension of our ability to use our
hands so the speech systems that we use
are you know very well-developed
motor very well-developed motor skill
and generally speaking your your
dominant linguistic hemisphere is the
same as your dominant hand and people
talk with their hands like me as you may
have noticed and we use sign language
and there's a tight relationship between
the use of the hand and the use of
language and that's partly because
language is a productive force and the
hand is part of it part of what changes
the world and so all those things are
tied together in a very very complex way
with this a priori structure and also
with the embodied structure and I also
think that's part of the reason why
classical Christianity puts such an
emphasis not only on the divinity of the
Spirit but also on the divinity of the
body this is a harder thing to grapple
with you know it's easier for people to
think if you think in religious terms at
all that you have some sort of
transcended spirit that somehow detached
from the body that might have some life
after death something like that but the
Christian Christianity in particular
really insists on the divinity of the
body so the idea is that there's an
underlying structure it's
this quasi patriarchal nature partly
because it's for complex reasons but
partly because it's a reflection of the
social structure as well as other things
and then that uses consciousness in the
form particularly of language but most
particularly in the form of truthful
language in order to produce the world
in a manner that's good and I think
that's a walloping powerful powerful
idea especially the relationship between
the idea that it's truthful speech that
gives rise to the good because that's a
really fundamental moral claim and I
think that's a tough one to beat man
because one of the things I've really
noticed is and then this and it isn't
just me that's for sure
is that you know there's a lot of
tragedy in life there's no doubt about
that
and lots of people that I see for
example in my clinical practice are laid
low by the tragedy of life but I also
see very very frequently that people get
tangled up in deceit in webs of deceit
that are often multiple generations long
and that just takes them out you know
and so that so deceit can produce
extraordinary levels of suffering that
lasts for very very long periods of time
and that's really a clinical truism you
know because Freud of course identified
one of the problems that contributed to
the suffering we might associate with
mental illness with repression which is
it's kind of like a lie of omission
that's a perfectly reasonable way to
think about it and you stated straight
out that there was no difference between
the psychotherapeutic the curative
psychotherapeutic effort and supreme
moral effort including truth that those
were the same thing as far as he was
concerned and Carl Rogers another great
clinician who was at one point a
Christian missionary before he became
more Moore's more strictly scientific he
believed that it was in truthful
dialogue that that that clinical
transformation took place and you know
it and of course one of the
prerequisites for genuine transformation
in the clinical setting is that the
therapist tells the truth and the client
tells the truth because otherwise how in
the world do you know what's going on
how can you solve the problem when you
don't even know what the problem is and
you don't know what the problem is
unless the person tells you the truth
that's something really to think about
in light of your own relationships
because you know if you don't tell the
people around you
the truth and they don't know who you
are and maybe that's a good thing you
know because well seriously people have
reasons to lie right I mean that aren't
trivial but it's really worth knowing
that you can't even get your hands on
the problem unless you formulate it
truthfully and if you can't get your
hands on the problem the probability
that you're going to solve it is it's
just so low and so then I've been
thinking about as well the this and this
idea has become more credible to me the
longer I've developed it the longer I
thought about it you know the idea that
there's oh go Bob it's partly the idea
that well let me let me figure out how
to start this property friend of mine
business partner and a guy that I've
written scientific papers with very
smart guy took me to task and I think I
told you this a little bit about using
the term dominance hierarchy which might
be fine for like chimpanzees and for
lobsters and for creatures like that but
not not first not not for chimpanzees
even so much and and he said something
very interesting he thought that the
idea of dominance hierarchy was actually
a projection of a early 20th century
quasi Marxist hypothesis onto the animal
kingdom that was being observed and the
notion that the hierarchical structure
that you see that characterizes say
mating hierarchies in chimps for example
the idea that that was predicated on
power was actually a projection of a
kind of political ideology and I thought
that really bugged me for a long time
when he said that because like because
I'd really been used to using the term
dominant IURC and I thought he told me
all that I thought that's so annoying
it's so annoying because it might be
right and then it took me months to
think about it and then I and then I was
also reading funds to all at the same
time and he's a primatologist and also
Jaak panksepp because he was a brilliant
brilliant effective neuroscientist who
unfortunately just died he wrote a great
book called aspect of neuroscience and
for rats to play they have to play fair
or they won't play with each other and
that's that's a staggering discovery
right because anything that helps
instantiate the emergence of ethical
behavior in animals and that associates
it with an evolutionary process which is
essentially what what pays up was doing
gives credence to the notion that the
ethics that guide us are not near social
logical epiphenomena constructs their
deep deeply rooted if flat and that
they're rats for God's sake he can't
trust them and they still play fair you
know and the will notice that the chimp
troops that he studied but it wasn't
wasn't the barber barbaric chimp that
ruled with an iron fist that was the
successful ruler because he kept getting
torn to shreds by his by the compatriots
that he ignored and stomped on Susie
showed some weakness they just tear him
into pieces
the chimp leaders that were stable you
know that had a stable Kingdom let's say
we're very reciprocal in terms of their
interactions with their friends and
chimps have friends and they out they
actually last for very long time chimp
friendships and they were also very
reciprocal in their interactions with
the females and with the infants and I
thought that's what friends the wall is
a very smart guy and I thought that was
also foundational science because it's
really something to note that the
attributes that give rise to dominance
in a male dominance hierarchy sort of
use that word let's call it authority
that might be better or even shudder
competence which I think is a better way
of thinking about it is that that's not
predicated purely on anything that's
that's that's as simple as brute power
and I think too you know I think as well
that the idea and this is a deeply
devious and dangerous political idea in
my estimation the idea that male
dominance hierarchies sorry male
hierarchies are fundamentally predicated
on power in a little in a law-abiding in
a law-abiding society I think is I think
all you fu think about that for like a
month say she's not long to understand
how absurd that is because most people
who are in positions of authority let's
say are just as hemmed in by ethical
responsibilities or even more so than
people at the other levels of the of the
hierarchy and we know this even in the
managerial literature because we know
generally speaking that managers are
more stressed by their subordinates than
the subordinates are stressed by their
managers and that's not surprising you
want to be responsible for like 200
people you really want that that's hard
work man and I mean I know it's a pain
to have a boss because the
to care about what the boss thinks and
maybe the person is arbitrary which case
they're not going to be particularly
successful but it's no joke to be
responsible for 200 people and you have
to behave very carefully when you're in
a position of responsibility and
authority like that because you will get
called out if you make mistakes
constantly so it's not like you're it's
not like because you have a position
that's higher up in the hierarchy that
you're less constrained by ethical
necessity now if you're a psychopath
well that's a whole different story but
Psychopaths have to move pretty rapidly
from hierarchy to hierarchy right
because they get found out quite quickly
and as soon as their reputation is
shattered then they can't get away with
their shenanigans anymore so okay so all
of this is to say that there is
something very interesting about the
pattern of behavior so imagine that
imagine that sexual selection is working
something like this and we know that
sexual selection is a very very very
very powerful biological force even
though biologists ignored it for almost
a hundred years after Charles Darwin
originally wrote about it thinking
mostly about natural selection they
didn't like the idea of sexual selection
because it tended to introduce the
notion of mind into the process of
evolution because it deals with choice
you know but so imagine on the one hand
that you have a male hierarchy we know
that the men at the top of the hierarchy
are much more likely to be reprimanded
the boil it's particularly true of men
so you have twice as many female
ancestors as you have male ancestors not
going to do the math but and I know it
doesn't sound plausible but you could
look it up and figure it out it's it's
perfectly reasonable fact that actually
happens to be true
so there's twice as if twice as many
female ancestors because females are
twice as likely on average to leave
offspring as men now what happens is any
man man who does reproduce tends to
reproduce more than once but a bunch of
the reproduce zero whereas so it would
be the average man who reproduces has
two children and the average man who
doesn't reproduce have zero obviously
and the average woman who reproduces has
one child so that means that there's
twice as many females in your line as
there is males so that that's a big deal
and and so imagine that it works
something like this so the men elect
the competent men who are admired and
who are and who are I can't say dominant
who are who are given positions of
authority and respect let's put it that
way and it's like an election now it
could be an actual democratic election
but it's at least an election of
consensus or it's at least an election
of well we're not going to kill him for
now which is also a form of election
right it's a form of Tolerance you know
so so and then what happens is the women
for their part peel from the top of the
mental hierarchy and so you've got two
factors that are driving human sexual
selection across vast stretches of
evolutionary time one is the election of
men by men to positions where they're
much more likely to reproduce and the
second is the tendency of women to peel
off the top of dáil dominant turkeys
which is extraordinarily well
established cross culturally even if you
flatten out the socio-economic disparity
say between men and women like they've
done in Scandinavia you don't you don't
reduce the tendency of women to peel off
the top of the male hierarchy by much
and why would you I mean women are smart
why in the world wouldn't they go for
four
why wouldn't they strive to make
relationships with men who are
relatively successful and why wouldn't
they let the men themselves define why
that how that constitutes success it
makes sense like if you want to figure
out who the best man is why not let the
men compete and the man who wins
whatever the competition is is the best
man by definition how else would you
define it so okay so why am I telling
you all that well the reason is is
because it seems to me that there's this
comp this being this complex interplay
across human evolution between the
election of the male dominance hierarchy
and sexual success and that's a big deal
if it's true it could be because what
would happen you see is that as men
evolved they would evolve to be better
and better at climbing up the male
hierarchy because the ones who weren't
good at that wouldn't reproduce so
obviously that's going to happen but
then it wouldn't just be a hierarchy
because there's a whole bunch of
different hierarchies and so then you
might say well are there commonalities
across hierarchies
reasonable thing to propose it mean
they're not completely opposed to one
another at least if you're more success
relatively more successful in run
hierarchy then you're more probable it's
more probable that you'll be successful
in another and that's actually a really
good definition of general intelligence
or IQ and that's actually one of the
things that women select men for now men
also select women for that but the
selection pressure is even higher from
women to men and general IQ is one of
the things that propels you up across
dominant turkeys because it's a general
problem-solving mechanism and the other
thing that seems to do that to some
degree is conscientiousness and there's
also some evidence that women prefer
conscientious men so and of course why
wouldn't they because you can trust them
and and and and and they work and so
those are both good things so then you
think okay so men have adapted to start
to climb the male dominance hierarchy
but it's the set of all possible
hierarchies that they're adapted to
climb and so then you think there's
there's a set of attributes that can be
acted out that and that can be embodied
that will increase the probability that
you're going to rise to the top of any
given hierarchy and then you could say
well that as you adapt to that fact then
you start to develop an understanding of
what that pattern constitutes and so
that starts to become the abstract
representation of something like
multi-dimensional competence and that's
like the abstraction of virtue itself
well and none of that has them none of
that's arbitrary now and that's as
bloody well grounded in biology if
anything could be and I think that's a
really hard argument to refute and like
one of the things I should tell you
about how I think is that when I think
something I spend a long time trying to
figure out if it's wrong you know
because I like to hack at it from every
possible direction to see if it's a weak
idea because if it's a weak idea then
I'd rather just dispense with it and
find something better and I've had a
real hard time trying to figure out
what's wrong with that idea I it seems
to me that it's pretty damn solid and
then the idea that you know if you watch
what people do in movies and so on and
when they're reading fiction it's
obvious that they're very good at
identifying both the hero and the
antihero we could say the antihero
generally speaking the bad guy is
someone who strives for authority and
position but fails
generally speaking not always but fail
so he's a good bad example a kid you
take a kid to a good guy bad guy movie
the kid takes out pretty fast that he's
not supposed to be the bad guy and and
figures out very quickly to zero in on
the good guy and that means that there's
there's an affinity between the pattern
of good guy that's being played out in
the fiction and the perceptual capacity
of the child you know and one of the
things I told my son when he was a kid I
used to take him to movies that were
sometimes more frightening than they
should have been but one of the things I
always told him was I never said don't
be afraid because I think that's bad
advice for kids what I said was keep
your eye on the hero right keep your eye
on the hero and again he was gripped by
the movie and often quite afraid of them
you know because movies can be very
frightening so he just like zero in on
that guy and hoping and you know what
it's like in a movie you hope that the
good guy wins generally speaking and I
mean why do you do that where does that
where does that come from you see how
deeply rooted that is inside you you'll
bloody well go line up and pay to watch
that happen it's not an easy thing to
understand and it's it's so self-evident
to people that we don't even notice that
it's a tremendous mystery and so is it
so unreasonable to think that we would
have actually over the millennia come to
some sort of collective conclusion about
what the best of the best guys are best
of the good guys are and what the worst
of the bad guys are and to me
architect Lee speaking thinking of that
as the hostile brothers so that's Christ
and Satan or Cain and Abel for example
very common mythological motif the
hostile brothers it's like those are
those those are archetypes it's like the
Satan for example is by definition the
worst that a person can be and Christ by
definition this is independent of
anything but conceptualization is by
definition the best today that a man can
be now as I said speaking
psychologically and conceptually but I
given our capacity for imagination and
our ability to engage in fiction and our
love for fiction and our capacity to
dramatize and our love for the story
stories of heroism and catastrophe and
and good and evil I can't see how it
could
any other way like so well so so that's
part of the idea that's driving the
notion of the evolution of the idea of
God and even more specifically driving
the evolution of the idea at least in
part of the Trinity so God is an
abstracted ideal formulated in large
part to dissociate the ideal from any
particular incarnation or man or any
ruler and there's another rule in the
biblical stories which is that when the
actual ruler I've mentioned this before
when the actual ruler becomes confused
with the abstracted ideals then the
state immediately turns into a tyranny
and the whole bloody thing collapses so
the idea it's so sophisticated you know
one of the things that we figured out
and this was a hard thing to figure out
was that you had to take the abstraction
and divorce it from any particular power
structure and then think about it as
something that existed as an abstraction
but a real thing right real and that it
governed your behavior in everyone's
behavior including the damned king the
king was responsible to the abstracted
ideal man that's an impossible that is
such an impossible ideal you know why
would if they agreed that 5000 years ago
but one of the things you see
continually happening in the Old
Testament is that as soon as the
Israelite for example the Israelite
Kings become almighty the real God comes
along and just cuts them into pieces and
then the whole bloody state falls apart
for like hundreds of years it's like I
think that's a lesson that that we have
not thoroughly consciously yet learned
it's still implicit in the narratives we
still haven't figured out why that's the
case
again I think that's a real hard
argument to to to dispense with so all
right so we looked at this a little bit
the Trinitarian idea is that there's a
there's a father that's maybe the
dramatic representation of the
structures that underlie consciousness
the embody structures that underlie
consciousness and then there's the son
and that's that that's consciousness but
in its particular historical form that's
the thing that's so interesting about
the figure of the son and then there's
consciousness as such and that seems to
be something like the
the indwelling spirit and so I mean
these psychological ideas came from
somewhere right that they have a history
they didn't just spring out of nowhere
and they emerge from from dreams and
hypothesis and artistic visions and all
of that over a long time and maybe they
get clarified into something like
consciousness but it takes a long time
to get from to get from watching you
know from to chimpanzees watching each
other to a human being saying well we're
we all we all exhibit this faculty
called consciousness I mean that's a
long journey you know that's a really
long journey and there's going to be
plenty of stages in between one of the
things I really like about Jean Piaget
the developmental psychologist was that
he was so insistent that children act
out and dramatized ideas before they
understand them and and Merlin Donald
who's a psychologist at Queen's
University wrote a couple of interesting
books along those lines at all as well
looking at the importance of imitation
for the development of higher cognition
in human beings and so the notion that
we embody ideas before we abstract them
out and then represent them in an
articulated way I think is an
extraordinarily solid idea and I really
can't see how it could be any other way
and if you watch children you see that
like think about what a child is doing
when he plays house or she plays house
you know the child acts out the father
or the mother but what's so interesting
about me to think well look isn't that
cute she's imitating her mother it's
like no she's not that's not what
happens because when your child imitates
you it's very annoying because you move
your arm and then they move their arm
and you know that you move your head to
copy you no one likes that it's direct
direct imitation that's not what a child
is doing with the child is playing what
the child is doing is watching the
mother over multiple instantiations and
then extracting out the spirit called
mother and that's whatever if mother
like across all those multiple
manifestations and then laying out that
pattern internally and manifesting
itself in an abstract world it's so
sophisticated it's just I'm that's what
you're doing when you're playing house
or having a tea partier or taking care
of a doll it's not
you've seen your mother take care of a
doll you haven't seen that it's that
you're smart enough to pull out the
abstraction and then embody it and
certainly the child is attempting to
strive towards an ideal at that point
you know she's not lighting her doll on
fire you know well with you know certain
exceptions but generally ones that we
try to not encourage right so so you see
that capacity in the children and it's
something we also know that if children
don't don't engage in that sort of
dramatic and pretend play to a
tremendous degree that they don't they
don't get properly socialized it's
really a critical element of developing
self understanding and then also
developing the capability of being with
others because what you do when you're a
child especially around the age of four
is you jointly construct a shared
fictional world will play house together
let's say and then you act out your
joint roles within that shared fictional
world you know and and that's a form of
very advanced cognitions very
sophisticated I see that and Piaget did
as well and so did you and so did Freud
these brilliant observers and also
Merlin Donald these brilliant observers
of the manner in which cognition came to
be they noted very clearly that embodied
imitation and dramatic abstraction
constituted the ground out of which
higher abstract cognition emerged enough
how could it not be because obviously we
were mostly bodies before we were minds
clearly and so we were acting out things
way before we understood them just like
the chimpanzees act out the idea that
you know you have to act reasonably
sensibly if your head chimpanzee or
you're going to get yourself ripped
apart and you see that rules because
when wolves have a dominance dispute you
know they pump up their hair at each
other to look big and they they growl
and bark and you know they're very
menacing and one wolf chickens out rolls
over puts up his neck and basically what
he's saying is yeah I'm pretty useless
so you could kill me if I want to if you
want to and the other wolf says yeah you
know you're pretty useless and I could
tear out your throat but tomorrow we
might need to bring down a wolf
or moves so I'll kick you out and and
it's not like they think that because
they don't know they don't think that
they acted out as a behavioral pattern
then if you're an anthropologist or a an
ethologist and you went and watched the
wolves you'd say it's as if they were
acting according to the following rule
and that often confused me because I
thought well the wolves act black wolves
act out rules and I thought no no a rule
is what we construct when we articulate
a behavioral pattern right we observe a
stable behavioral pattern and when we
articulate it we can call it a rule but
for the Wolves it's not a rule it's just
a stable behavioral pattern and so we
acted like wolf troops or chimpanzee
troops all of that when well i'm firfer
untold really untold tens and perhaps
hundreds of millions of years before we
were able to formulate that pattern of
behavior at anything approximating a
story or the image and and even longer
before we could articulate it as a set
of ethical rules and I'm dwelling this I
know I've repeated some of this before
but it's so important because you know
there's this tremendous push especially
from the social the social
constructionist to make the case that
ethics is arbitrary ethics is morality
is relative there's no fundamental
biological grounding in relationship to
human behavior especially in the in the
category of ethics and I think that
that's well first of all it's dangerous
because that means that people are
anything you want to turn them into and
you bloody well better be careful of
people who think that and second I just
think that the evidence that that's
wrong is so overwhelming that we should
just stop thinking that way I mean the
and that's probably why I'm also
attacking this from an evolutionary
perspective there's lots of converging
lines of evidence that ethic ethical
standards of at least of the most of the
most crucial store sort not only evolve
but also spontaneously re-emerge for
example in the dramatic play of children
so we need to take that seriously and so
well that's partly what we're doing here
trying to take that seriously so
okay so the idea there at least in part
was that the father employed the Sun to
generate habitable order out of chaos I
also think there might be something more
approximately true about that as well
too because one of the things we do know
there's something that's cool about men
men are much more criminal than women
and that by the way that does not look
like it's socio-cultural partly because
it Peaks when testosterone kicks in
around 14
like it just spikes the hell up and then
it really it stays pretty high until
about 27 and so standard penological
theory for those of you who don't know
this is that if you have a repeat
offender you know a guy who just won't
stop getting in trouble yes home in
prison till he's 28 and it isn't like
you're rehabilitating him or anything
it's like by 28 he's done with his
criminal career because the crime curve
is peaks at 15 and then falls down
around 27 or so it burns out and that's
often by the way that's often that's
that's often when men get married and
settle down and stabilized
one of the things that's one of the
things that's cool about that is the
creativity curve for men is almost
exactly the same thing it ramps up when
testosterone kicks in and then it starts
to flatten out around 27 that curves
match very very closely so that's so
that's that's quite cool
it's the creativity element of it that
I'm particularly interested in because
the creativity is in many ways it
attributed youth and that's look I mean
if you look at that sentence and you've
stripped it of its religious context
what you would say is that well the
older people use the younger people to
generate creative ideas and renew the
world it's like yeah that's that's what
happens and you you know you also have
no idea how many of the things that we
discovered or invented as human beings
were stumbled across by children and
adolescence you know because they're
well they're much more exploratory
they're less constrained by their by
their already extent knowledge
structures and they're less conservative
so yeah that seems just right to me so
and right in an extraordinarily
important way because it also means that
it's like if you're an actual father one
of the things that it means is that
that's part of what you should be
encouraging your son to do right which
is which is does the rail of a father is
to encourage that is clearly the role
and to encourage is to say well go out
there confront the chaos of the unknown
and the chaos that underlies everything
and drop it with it you know how because
you can do it here as big as the chaos
itself and you know do something useful
as a consequence and makes your life
better and make everyone else's life
better and you know you can do it and
man that's the right thing to tell
that's the right thing to tell young men
you know talking to young women is more
complicated because they have more more
let's say issues to deal with because
their lives are more complicated in some
ways but that's definitely the right
thing to be to be telling your your son
and one of the things that I've really
noticed recently since I've been
lecturing especially in the last seven
or eight months most of my audiences
being young men and and I've talked a
lot of them too a lot I've talked a lot
to them about both truth and
responsibility and I think that those
those are the two things that underlie
this capacity and it there seems to me
to be a tremendous hunger for that idea
it's not the same idea as right you know
it's very different ideas it's a
counterpart to right and so it's you
know life is hard it's chaotic it's
difficult it's really definitely a
challenge and so you can either shrink
from that and no bloody wonder because
you know it's going to kill you it's not
it's no joke man where you can
front it and try to do something about
it well what's better and and then you
say to the person look man you could do
it like that's what a human being is
like and if you just stood up and got
yourself together and you find out by
trying that you can in fact do that and
I do think that that's that's a great
core religious message as far as I can
tell and I think that's deeply embedded
in this sort of in this sort of idea so
all right so this is what I've been
telling you this is something like how
knowledge itself is generated first of
all there's the unknown as
and that's really what you don't know
anything about and generally when you
encounter that you don't encounter it
with thought you encounter it like this
right and that that's the first
representation of the absolutely unknown
it's something that is beyond your
comprehension and it's terrifying and
because it's beyond your comprehension
you cannot perceive it you cannot
understand it but you still have to deal
with it and the way you deal with it is
that you freeze that's what the that's
what a basilisk does say to the to the
kids in Harry Potter right they take a
look at it and they freeze that's the
snake the terrible snake of chaos that
lives underneath everything you see that
that thing freezes you and that's
because you're a prey animal but at the
same time it makes you curious and so
that's the first level of contact with
the absolute unknown is the emotional
combination of freezing and curiosity
and that's reflected I think in the
Dragon stories the dragon is the
terrible thing that lives underground
Accords gold or hoards virgins very very
strange behavior for reptile as we
pointed out before but the idea is that
it's a symbolic representation of the
predatory quality of the unknown
combined with the capacity of the
unknown to generate nothing but novel
information and it's very you can see
that is very characteristic of human
beings because we are prey animals but
we're also unbelievably exploratory and
we're pretty damn good predators and we
occupy this weird cognitive niche and so
one of the things we've learned is that
if we forth lightly confront the unknown
terrifying as it is there's a massive
prize to be gained continually and so
that seems to be true right it's true as
anything is and then I would also say
that that idea and we know that one of
the metaphors that underlies gods
extraction of habitable order out of
chaos at the beginning of time is an
older idea and a more archaic idea that
God confronted something like the
Leviathan and that's one of the words
for this serpent like chaos creature
that's often used in the Old Testament
or the Leviathan and they beat them on
yeah that's the other thing and so
there's this idea that I think came
probably came from the Mesopotamia
that the God either in the sun-like
aspect or in the father like aspect is
the thing that confronts this terrible
beast that represents the chaotic
unknown and cuts it into pieces and then
sometimes gives the body parts to the
populace in order to feed them so you
can see a hunting metaphor there as well
but it's deeper than that
and so all right so the first thing is
there's the absolute unknown and the
unknown is what you do not understand
it's what's beyond the campfire maybe
it's what's beyond the tree even more
anciently an old word when we when we
lived in trees it's out there that where
you don't know and what's out there
crocodiles and snakes and birds of prey
and cats and all sorts of things like
predatory cats and they will eat you but
there's utility and going out there to
find out what's there like maybe you go
and you don't kill the snake you kill
the damn nest of snakes and that makes
you pretty popular just as you should be
that accelerates your your rep reductive
potential let's say and we're descended
from people who did that and so we have
this notion about how the world is
structured that's deeply embedded in our
psyche like really really deeply way way
down way below the surface cognition way
down in the limbic system in these
ancient parts of the brain that are like
60 million years old or a hundred
million years old or older than that
ancient ancient brain structures and so
the first thing we do is we act out our
encounter with the unknown world and we
act that out in the same way in a manner
that's analogous to the manner that's
presented as a description of what it is
that God does at the beginning of time
to extract habitable order out of chaos
and I I will tell you about the other
part of that for now so you act it out
first and then the second thing is you
watch people who act it out and you
start to make representations of that
that's stories right and maybe you
admire them and then after a long time
you collect a bunch of those stories and
then you can say what that is you can
articulate it as a pattern and so and
this is something Nietzsche also figured
out to begin with you know because prior
to Nietzsche I would say he did so many
things first it was quite remarkable you
know there was an idea that you first
think and then you act and then people
like to think that of course you do it
bloody rubbish because you're impulsive
as you can possibly imagine you're
always doing things before you think and
sometimes that's a really good idea so
the idea that you see things and then
think and then act it's like you really
know I'm sorry did I don't do that I
know one I know I know does that and
they certainly do that don't do that
when they're emotional you know you act
first and one of the things that
Nietzsche said very clearly was that our
ideas emerged out of the ground of our
action over over thousands and thousands
of years and then when philosophers were
putting forward those ideas what they
were doing wasn't generating creative
ideas they were just telling the story
of humanity it's already there it's
already in us it's already in our
patterns of behavior and and it strikes
me that that's well he was a genius and
that was one of the genius one of his
many many observations of pure genius
and so you can think about it you know
you can think about it like this too is
that there's unknown and then you act in
the face of the unknown and then you you
dream about the action and that's what
you're doing in a movie theater and then
you speak about it and so you know and
of course once you speak about it that
affects how you dream and how you dream
affects how you act it's not like the
all of the causal direction is it was
one way because it's not deep these
things loop but it's still from the
unknown through the body through the
imagination into articulation that's the
primary mode of the generation of of
wisdom let's say and you can easily map
that onto an evolutionary explanation
because the body comes first right and
then is the imagination which is the
body in abstraction and only then the
word and of course that's exactly how
things did evolve because we could
imagine things long before we could
speak at least that's the theory so and
I represented that this is a image from
my book maps of meaning and so so the
idea is that this is the fundamental
representation of the unknown as such
it's half spirit because it partakes of
the air like a bird and it's half matter
because it's on the ground like a like a
like a
make and and that's what you think is
there when you don't know what is there
that's how your body reacts to what's
you know that too because if you're
alone at night you know it maybe you're
a little rattled up for one reason other
maybe you watched a horror movie and you
know there's some weird noise in the
other room it's dark and you could just
try this once it's like so you're on
edge
you think you want to turn the light on
and go in the room and see don't do that
just open the door a little bit and
sneak your hand in and just watch what
your imagination fills that room with
right and then then you remember what
it's like to be three years old in bed
in afraid of the dark
right and I read a good book on dragons
lately recently that that that had a
very interesting hypothesis about them I
thought one of the things the guy did
was track I can't remember his name
unfortunately track how common the image
of the dragon was worldwide it's
unbelievably widespread it's crazily
widespread and he thought that this was
actually the category of primate
predator and the predator was so
predator is a weird category right
because like there's there's crocodiles
in it and there's lions and they don't
have much in common except they eat you
so it's a functional category and so
this is the this is the imagistic
representation of the functional
category of predator and his predator
theory was well if you're a monkey then
a bird would pick you off like an eagle
and so that's this right and then if it
wasn't eagle it was a cat as they climb
teary trees and give you a good chomping
and then if it wasn't a cat and you go
down to the ground and a snake would get
you or maybe a snake would climb up the
tree because snakes like to do that and
get you and so that's a pre cat snake
basically free cat snake bird and that's
the thing you really that's the thing
you're really want to avoid you don't
want to come across one of those and so
and then you know the other thing it
does is breathe fire which is quite
interested because obviously fire was
both greatest friend and greatest enemy
of humanity and we've mastered fire for
a long time it might be as long as two
or three million years
that's what Richard rang him I think
it's rang ham he wrote a book recently
on I think it was Ragan
who wrote a book on when human beings
learned to cook that was about two
million years ago and cooking increased
the increase the availability of
calories you know how chimpanzees are
sort of shaped like a big like they're
ugly they're shaped like a big bowling
ball you know they're really they look
really fat and it's and they're short
and they're wide and that's because they
have intestinal tracts that are like you
know 300 miles long and the reason for
that is because they have to digest
leaves and so you go out in the forest
and like sit there and eat leaves for a
whole day and see how that works out for
you you know yeah they have no calories
in them so chimps spend about inkless I
think it's eight hours a day chewing and
it's because what they eat has no
nutritional value and then they have to
have this tremendous guts in order to
extract anything at all out of it human
beings at some point just thought Oh to
hell with that we'll cook something and
then we traded our guts for brain which
you know more or less has worked and I
think it's made us a lot more attractive
as well so okay well so the idea here
was that well that's the basic archetype
of the unknown as such and then I like
the st. George version of this it's so
cool because st. George lives in a like
a castle and the castle is partly
falling down and it's partly because
there's a dragon that's come up to like
it's an eternal dragon it's come back to
giver who in a rough time which always
happens because there isn't the eternal
dragon is always given are giving our
fallen down castles a rough time always
and so then st. George's the hero who
goes out to confront the dragon and he
frees the Virgin from its grasp and I
would say that's a pretty
straightforward story about the sexual
attractiveness of the masculine spirit
that's willing to forthrightly encounter
the unknown that's it looks just
straight looks like a straight
biological representation to me and it's
a really really old story right it's the
oldest written story we have and that's
basically the Mesopotamian creation myth
the Anu male ish which which basically
lays out precisely that story and so and
it's replayed I mean I bet you the movie
goers among you especially the ones that
are more attracted to the superhero you
know they're really flashy sort of
superhero type movies you've probably
seen the st. George story like 150 times
in the last 10 years you never get tired
of it because it's the central
story of mankind so you've got the
unknown as such and that is what you
react to with your body in the
existential terror and extraordinary
curiosity are gripping you and then it's
like the unknown unknowns that who's the
politician under Bush Rumsfeld yeah I
think the reason that that phrase caught
on so well is because he nailed an
archetype
there's unknown unknowns and there's
known unknowns and that's the unknown
unknown and you have to be able to react
to an unknown unknown because they can
get you and you can't just plead
ignorance because then you're dead that
doesn't work like human beings are the
sort of creature who has to know what to
do when they don't know what to do and
that's very paradoxical and what we do
is we prepare to do everything that's
right we're on guard we prepare to do
everything very very stressful and but
also very engaging and very very much
something that heightens consciousness
and maybe those circuits are permanently
turned on in human beings because we
also know that we're going to die and no
other animal knows that and so sometimes
I think that our that our stress
circuits are just on all the time and
that's part of what accounts for our
heightened consciousness so you have
your unknown unknowns and then you have
your relatively you have the unknowns
that you actually encounter in the world
like the mystery of your of your
romantic partner when you have a fight
with them it's like well we're having a
fight who the hell are you I mean you're
not the absolute unknown because I know
something about you but you're the
unknown as its manifesting itself to me
right now right and and and then there's
a known that we inhabit and then there's
the knower and the known is given
symbolic representation as far as I've
been able to tell in patriarchal form in
the form of male deities and the unknown
as you encountered it's given feminine
form so we won't get into that too much
but but if you're interested in that you
could look at my maps of meetings
lectures or maybe take a look at the
book but I think it's a good I think
it's a good schema for religious
archetypes I've worked on a long time it
seems to fit the union criteria quite
nicely it maps nicely onto Joseph
Campbell's ideas he got almost all has
ideas from you however and it also makes
sense from a biological and an evolution
a perspective as far as I can tell
that's a lot of cross validation at
least in my estimation so okay so back
to the hierarchy of dominance well let's
take a look at it a little bit so I'm
quite enamored of lobsters as some of
you might know because I found out this
just blew me away when I found it out I
mean I I've done a lot of work in neuro
chemistry some similar chemistry because
I used to study alcoholism and drug
abuse and alcoholism to study alcohol
you have to know a lot about the brain
because alcohol goes everywhere in the
brain it affects every neural chemical
system and so if you're going to study
alcohol it kind of has to study neuro
chemistry in general and so I did that
for quite a long time I really got in a
Murud of a book called the neuro
psychology of anxiety by Jeffery gray
which is an absolute work of genius
although extraordinarily did I don't
know how many references that book has
it's like must be a thousand and gray
actually read them and worse he
understood them and then and then he and
then he integrated them into this book
and so to read it you have to really
master functional neural chemistry and
animal behaviorism and and motivation
and emotion and neural Anatomy like it's
a killer book but man it's really rich
and it's taken psychologists about 40
years to really unpack that book but one
of the things I learned about that was
just exactly how much continuity there
was in the neural chemistry of human
beings in the neural chemistry of
animals it's absolutely staggering it's
the sort of thing that makes the fact of
evolution something like self evident I
do think it's self-evident for other
reasons that I'll tell you about later I
think evolution or I think natural
selection random mutation and natural
selection is the only way you can solve
the problem of how to deal with an
environment that's complex beyond your
ability to comprehend I think what you
do is you generate endless variants
because god only knows what the hell's
going to happen next they all almost all
of them die because they're failures and
a couple propagate and you know the
environment keeps moving around like a
giant snake you never know what it's
going to do next and so the best you can
do is say well here's thirty things that
might work and you know twenty-eight of
them are going to perish if you're if
you're an insect it's like the ratio is
way way higher than that so anyways back
to the lobsters
in all of these so these creatures
engage in in dominance disputes and and
I think dominance is the right way to
think about it because lobsters aren't
very empathic and they're not very
social and so it really is the toughest
lobster that wins you know and what's so
cool about the lobster is that when a
lobster wins he flexes and gets bigger
so he looks bigger because he's a winner
it's like he's advertising that and the
biological the neurochemical system that
makes him flex is serotonergic and you
think well who cares what the hell does
that mean well tell you what it means
it's the same chemical that's affected
by antidepressants in human beings and
so like if you're depressed you're a
defeated lobster like you're like this
I'm small I'm not you know things are
dangerous I don't want to fight you give
someone an antidepressant it's like up
they stretch and then they're ready to
like take on the world again well if you
give lobsters who just got defeated in
the fight serotonin then they stretch
out and they'll fight again and that's
like we separated from those creatures
on the evolutionary timescale somewhere
between 350 and 600 million years ago
and the damn neuro chemistry is the same
and so that's another indication of just
how important hierarchies of authority
are I mean they've been conserved since
the time of lobsters right there weren't
trees around when lobsters first first
manifested themselves on the planet and
so what that means is these hierarchies
that I've been talking about those
things are older than trees and so one
of the truisms for what constitutes real
from a Darwinian perspective is that
which has been around the longest period
of time right because it's had the
longest period of time to exert
selection pressure well we know we
evolved and lived in trees something on
the order of 60 million years ago we're
talking ten times as far back as that
for the hierarchy and so the idea that
human beings that the hierarchy is
something that has exerted selection
pressure on human beings is I don't
think that's a disputable that's not a
disputable issue how it's done it and
exactly what that means we can argue
about but like that sort of biological
continuity is just absolutely
unbelievable I it was funny because I
revealed this finding
I didn't discover this I read about it
but I talked to my graduate students
about I used to take them out for
breakfast you know and they were very
contentious snappy Bunch
and and they're always trying to one-up
each other and they're quite witty and
for like six months until it got very
annoying every time one of them went up
the other they'd stretch themselves out
like snap their hands like so that was
that was very funny it was really very
funny so you see this in lobsters and so
that's pretty amazing
so you know and one of the other thing
that's really cool about lobsters is
that let's say you've been like talk
lobster for a long time but you're
getting kind of old and some young
lobster just you know whales the hell
out of you and and so you're all
depressed but thing is your brain is
dominant but you don't have much of a
brain because you're a lobster and so
now what are you going to do because you
just lost and the answer is while your
brain will dissolve and then you'll grow
a subordinate brain yeah so that's we're
thinking about two right here for a
couple of reasons first of all if any of
you have ever been seriously defeated in
life you know what that's like it's like
it's a death a descent a dissolution and
if you're lucky a regrowth and and maybe
not as the same person that's what
happens to people with post-traumatic
stress disorder right their brains
undergo permanent neurological
transformation and they then inhabit a
world it's much more dangerous than the
world that they inhabited to begin with
but we also know - if you have
post-traumatic stress disorder or
depression that your hippocampus shrinks
right it dies and shrinks and you can
sometimes get it to grow back your
hippocampus shrinks and your amygdala
grows and the amygdala increases
emotional sensitivity and the
hippocampus inhibits emotional
sensitivity and so if you've been badly
defeated the hippocampus shrinks and the
amygdala grows now if you recover the
hippocampus will regrow and the
antidepressants actually seem to help
that but the damn amygdala never shrinks
again and so well so that's another
lesson from the lobster it's quite a
terrifying one but but it's one like
it's so interesting that you can relate
to that right it's like I get what that
poor crustacean is going through you
know
so okay here's the rats and this is from
yak Bank steps work rat he was the first
guy who figured out the rats giggle and
you might think well what kind of stupid
thing is that to study is like $50,000
research grant for giggling rats you
know aside but he discovered the play
circuitry in mammals that's a big deal
right it's like discovering a whole new
continent there's a play circuit enamels
it's built right in so it's not socially
constructed there's a there's a
biological platform for that and so what
panksepp would do with rats he found out
if rats if you take a rat puff away from
its mother it dies even if you feed it
even if you keep it warm it dies now you
can stop it from dying by taking a
pencil with an eraser on the end and
massaging it right because rats won't
live without love and the same thing
happens to human babies and we saw that
Romania when there was that catastrophe
have to tell chesco in the orphanages
where the orphanages were full of
unwanted babies because Ceausescu
insisted that every Romanian woman was
constantly pregnant so the orphan is
just stacked up with unwanted babies
lots of them didn't even have names and
they were warehoused warm shelter food
devastating lots of them died most of
them died before the first year and the
ones that didn't die were permanently
dysfunctional because you have to be
touched if you're a human being it's not
an option you have to be played with
it's not an option it's it's part of
neural developmental necessity and you
have to also play fair so because
otherwise you produce a very disjointed
child who isn't able to engage in the
niceties of social interaction which is
continual play in some sense and
reciprocity so what panksepp did with
his rat he noticed that male rats
juveniles really liked to wrestle and
they wrestle just like humans beings
wrestle they pinned each other for
crying out loud with like that that rat
has just lost he's down for a ten count
right and so so what you do is you take
juvenile rats and you can find out that
they want to play because you can attach
a spring to them and then they'll try to
run and you can measure how hard they're
running by how hard they're pulling on
the spring and then you can estimate how
motivated they are and so you can find
out that
well fed rat who doesn't have anything
on his mind will still work hard to play
if to enter an arena where he's been
allowed to play before he'll work for
that so that you think while the rats
motivated so the two rats go out there
and they play and and so they're playing
like dogs play and everyone knows what
that looks like if you're you know what
you have any sense about dogs they kind
of go like this and kids do that and
maybe you do that with your wife if
you're gonna play with her a little bit
okay my poor my poor wife man when she
huh she was a she was a young she had
older siblings and so she wasn't played
with as much when she was little as she
might have been and I used to like you
know what you take a pill away and you
go like this three times right that
means look out a pillow is coming your
way so I go one two three Wow but she
looked she was completely dismayed at me
like what do you do that for and I
thought well I eventually taught her
that rule the other thing I used to do
[Applause]
the only thing I used to do you know it
said sometimes she'd come at me like
this when we were playing round and I
grabbed her wrist and I'd knock her for
her for her hamsters heard not close
together she used to just get completely
annoyed about that and I thought right
that's what you do you just opened your
hands well she didn't know that either
so she hadn't been played with enough
when she was a little rat and so
anyways anyway so you let the route the
little rats go out there right and so
let's imagine one of them is 10% bigger
than other and so that the 10% bigger
rat wins because 10% is enough in rat
way to ensure that you're going to be
the Pinner rather than the penny okay so
so that's fine so a knit net the rat the
rat pins the big rat pins a little rat
and now the big rat is the is the
authority rat and so then the next time
that the rats play the little rod has to
invite the big rat to play so the big
rats out there being cool and a little
that pops up and you know does the whole
will you play with me thing and the big
rat will deign to play with it but if
you pair them repeatedly unless the big
rat lets the little rat win 30 percent
of the time so little rat will not
invite him to play and panksepp
discovered that it's like I read that
that just blew me away it's like that is
so amazing because you see well first of
their there's an analogy to psays ideas
about the emergence of morality out of
play and human being so that was very
cool but the notion that that was built
in to rats at the level of wrestling was
and their social they're deeply social
animals right they have to know how to
get along with one another and most of
their authority disputes dominance
disputes you don't want them to end in
bloodshed and combat because you know if
your rat won and I'm rat 2 and we tear
each other to shreds in a dominance
dispute rat 3 is just going to move in
it's really not a great strategy and so
be better if we could settle our
differences you know somewhat peacefully
and so while so rat anyway
Peg's had figured out that rats play and
not only did they play they play fair
and they seemed to enjoy it he also
figured out this was really cool to that
if you give juvenile rats attention
deficit disorder drugs ritalin
suppresses prey play so that's worth
thinking about it's like well why do you
have to give juvenile human beings
amphetamines in school well because they
need to play well you know they don't
get to play you know get to wrestle
around I mean that's oppression as far
as I can tell they don't get to wrestle
around that's fine feed them some
amphetamines man that'll shut down the
old play circuits well
is the other problem is panksepp found
out that if you don't let juvenile male
rats play their prefrontal cortexes
don't develop properly surprise surprise
you're not letting them ensure it's like
what else would you expect so you know
that's something to think about really
hard I would say so well so there's some
wolves going at it and we're all hunting
not exactly there's some moves having an
authority dispute but more technically
speaking and a lot of its posturing you
know they tend they tend not well
socialized wolves tend not to hurt each
other during authority disputes because
well for over obvious reasons it's too
dangerous and so they have other ways of
demonstrating who should be listen to
authorities and there's chimps doing you
have this particular house I think if I
remember correctly I think it's right
this is a really cool picture because I
think this chimp chimps don't like
snakes by the way so for example if you
take a chimp that's never seen a snake
and you show it a snake it is not happy
it will get the hell away from that
snake if you bring a chimp anesthetized
into a roomful of chimps the chips will
all get away from that and then look at
the body they don't like that either and
if you bring a big snake into a chimp
cage even if the chimps have never seen
it like they'll get away from it and
then stare at it and chimps out in the
wild if they see a big snake they'll
they'll stand there and they have a
noise that means it's like holy crap
that's a big snake you know it actually
means that technically I'll tell you why
in a minute
but they get they stand away from it
then they make this this noise which
means oh my god look at the snake and
then they'll stand there for like 24
hours looking at the snake and so the
snakes are really really they're super
stimuli for chimpanzees so that's pretty
interesting in this chimp seem to learn
how to take this dead snake and go scare
other chips with it and that was
that was hardly how he established his
authority and you know and while there
there's a there's a there's a threat and
you like if I was you and I was around
that chimp I would take that threat
seriously because those things are no
joke man and you see the same thing here
with the I don't remember what kind of
monkey that is but they're engaged in
agonistic behavior and so from so and
there has been by the way there has been
recent research showing that in higher
order primates that there is snake
detection circuitry that's built into
them right so it's not learned it's not
learned deeper than that now for a long
time psychologist psychologist knew for
a long time that I could make you afraid
in a conditioning experience experiment
much faster using a snake or a picture
of the snake than a gun or a picture of
a gun so we can learn fear to snakes
very rapidly spiders as well and so then
people thought well maybe we were
prepared to develop fear to snakes or
spiders that sort of thing but the more
recent research has indicated that it's
more than just prepared is that we have
the detection circuitry built right into
us and well is because well why wouldn't
we that's that's really the issue it's
like it's not really that much of a
surprise unless you think of human
beings as a blank slate and if you think
that been I don't know you should crawl
out of the 16th century that's that's
all I would look I would look at it
because I mean that's that's that's just
go on that idea it's it's it's so wrong
so so maybe you can think about this as
a dominance hierarchy but wolves look
for those wolves look for credibility
and competence as well and and
chimpanzees don't like brutal tyrants
and so we'll talk about it as the
hierarchy of authority and so well this
is kind of how it starts to develop you
know you see well these girls are
negotiating the domestic environment
here and how to behave properly and how
to share and all that and turn and take
turns and so they're negotiating the
hierarchy of authority and if you're
good at reciprocity it's sometimes
you're the authority and sometimes the
other person is the authority that's
fair play right and so these boys are
doing the same thing and you see they're
all smiling away and so it looks like
aggressive behavior and people who are
not
very attentive and who are paranoid and
who don't like human beings can confuse
this with aggression and they forbid it
at schools which is you know I know when
my kids were going to school for example
this was quite a while ago now they were
forbidden to pick up snow on the off
chance they might throw a snowball and
we know how terrible that is so what I
told my son was that he was perfectly
welcome to Pelt any teacher he wanted to
in the back of the head with the
snowball as long as he was willing to
suffer the consequences of doing it and
I don't know if he ever did but he was
happy with he was certainly happy with
the idea which made me very happy about
him so yeah so so you know kids need to
do this they really really seriously
need to do this it's what civilize --is
them and they that needs to happen
between the ages of two and four because
if they're not civilized by the time
they're 4 then you might as well just
forget it
and that's a that's a horrible statistic
but it's unbelievably well borne out in
the relevant developmental literature
like there's lots of aggressive
two-year-olds most of them are male and
if they stay aggressive past the age of
four they tend to be lifetime aggressive
they make no friends they're outcasts
they're much more likely to end up
antisocial criminal delinquent and in
jail and so your kids need to be
socialized between the ages of two and
four and that's particularly true for
the more aggressive males and most of
the rest of two-year-olds are male and
that isn't socialization by the way so
there's a more--not more abstract
representation of the same sort of thing
and I'm trying to make the case that
this that the that the hierarchy of
authority emerges out of a game-like
matrix an underlying game-like matrix
and that's one of the things that one of
the things that's so brilliant about
Jean Piaget he figured that out it's so
smart and he was interested in the
biological origin of morality and he
identified it he he he traced the origin
to play and the emergence of morality
out of play and that's it's so smart
it's just I just can't believe how smart
an idea that was because it's the
bottom-up construction of of morality
now Piaget was a constructionist and to
some degree social constructionist he
underestimated the role of
biology but that doesn't invalidate his
theory it's really easy to put a
biological underpinning underneath
underneath pas theory we know the
biology well enough to do it quite quite
nicely now so I mean we well the fact
that tanks have for example could
identify the play circuit is a really
good start with that right because play
has been around so long that we have a
circuit that's dedicated to it and so
that's that's a very very ancient that's
a very ancient issue and so you know
this is this is very much of an
abstraction of a game here and then of
course you get the ultimate abstraction
in representation what in a
representation like like that where even
though even the landscape of the game is
fictional and of course we've migrated
to a large degree into those sorts of
fictional landscapes fictional books
movies video games so it's the same it's
an extension of the same thing so
practice for practice for real life the
shades in some cases into real life
itself so alright more representations
of God the Father I like these
representations I like the triangle idea
I mean I don't know why God is wearing a
triangular hat it's kind of a strange
fashion choice but I think it's
associated with the idea of the pyramid
and I think that's associated with the
idea of the hierarchy of authority and I
think that's why the Egyptians put their
pharaohs inside pyramids I know there's
more to it than that but I think some of
that has to do with the notion of this
hierarchical structure you see this on
that now that's speculative obviously
and I don't want to make too much of it
but but I can't help but think that
there's something to that see that's on
the back of the American dollar bill I
like that a lot that's like the Eye of
Horus from the Egyptians and so the idea
here is something like at the top of the
hierarchy is something that is no longer
part of the hierarchy right so if you
move up the hierarchy enough what
happens is that you develop the ability
as a consequence of moving up that
hierarchy to be detached enough from the
hierarchy so you're no longer really
part of it and so that you can move in
all sorts of different hierarchies and
the thing the idea here is that the
thing that you're really developing is
the capacity to pay attention and I
would say from a from
mythological perspective the the one
thing that seems to compete with the
idea of the spoken word as the as the
source of the extraction of habitable
order from chaos is the I is the
capacity to pay attention so Marduk for
example the Mesopotamian Creator God who
emerged in the hierarchy of Mesopotamian
gods and came out at the top right he
was the victor of the gods he had eyes
all the way around his head and he could
speak magic words and I really like that
I really like that idea and the
Egyptians developed that idea too
because their god Horus was the eye
everyone knew was the Eye of Horus that
that sense that image is so compelling
that we still know about everybody has
seen the Eye of Horus with a really open
pupil and what the Egyptians learned was
that the open eye was what revivified
the Dead Society it's so smart so what
do you do if your life isn't in order
bloody well pay attention and that isn't
the same as thinking it's a different
process paying attention thinking is
like the imposition of structure in some
sense I know I'm oversimplifying but
paying attention is something like
watching for what you don't know and so
like one of the things I often recommend
to my clinical clients if they're having
trouble with a family member is number
one shut up don't tell them anything
about yourself just and I don't mean in
a rude way it's just like no more
personal information number two watch
them like a hawk and listen and if you
do that long enough they will tell you
exactly what they're up to and they will
also tell you who they think you are and
then you'll be shocked because they
think you're something generally
speaking that's not like you what you
are at all and when they tell you it's
like a revelation to both of you but
attention is an unbelievably powerful
force and you see this in psychotherapy
too because a lot of what you do and in
any reparative relationship is really
pay attention to another person pay
attention and listen and you would not
believe what people will tell you or
reveal to you if you watch them as if
you want to know instead of watching
them so that you'll have your prejudices
reinforced that's usually how people
interact is like I want to keep thinking
about you the way I'm thinking about you
and so I'm going to filter out anything
that just proves my theory that's not
what I'm talking about at all it's like
I'm going to watch you and figure out
what you're up to not in a rude way none
of that I just want to see what's there
and that'll be good for you probably and
also be good for me and so well so
that's the idea that you know climbing
up a hierarchy of authority can give you
vision and that vision can transcend the
actual hierarchy and I think that's also
the I think that's also the that's the
metaphysical space that an artist
occupies because artists really aren't
in a hierarchy there outside of
hierarchies you've watched the Lion King
most of you yeah that's that zoo you
know the little bird that's the eye of
the king that's the same thing there so
and that's that's echoed in this idea as
well so so well that's some more more
ideas of hierarchies same idea this is
right gold silver bronze why gold gold
is the Sun Gold is pure right so the
idea is that the thing that's at the top
of the hierarchy is incorruptible
because gold doesn't mix with anything
else right it's this sort of metal that
doesn't ever become corrupted it's a
noble metal it doesn't become corrupted
and so it shines like the Sun and it's
associated with what's ever at the top
of the hierarchy and the gold the gold
medal is a disc like the Sun and it's
awarded to those people who occupied the
top position and who are manifestations
of the ideal and here's here's I can
tell you a quick story so imagine that
you're watching an Olympic contest
I found this happens to me very often
with gymnastics because the gymnasts are
so absolutely unbelievable you know so
you go watch the gymnastic performance
and the verse is out there bouncing
around like you know you can't even
imagine doing it they're so perfect at
it so you see this person they're going
through this routine they're just
absolutely spectacular and flawless at
it you know at the end they stop and
everybody claps and and they're all
excited to see what a human being can do
and that's why we're in the audience
watching because we want to see what a
human being can do and the judges go
like 9.8 9.8 9.8 everybody's thrilled
and then the next contestant comes out
and it's like well they're just
basically screwed right it's like this
person came out there and was perfect
how are you going to top that that's an
interesting question because this
is a representation of what you do to
top perfection itself and you can do it
and here's how you do it and you know
this even though you don't know you know
it so let's say the next contestant
comes out they're kind of shaky because
it's like oh man the bar is being raised
high so what they do is they put
themselves right on the edge of chaos
and you can tell by watching them that
they are one bloody fraction of a second
from catastrophe they're pushing
themselves farther than they've ever
gone in the direction of their
perfection and everyone in the room is
so tense they can hardly stand it right
you can hear a pin drop and that person
is flipping around it they're just it's
just right on the edge of catastrophe
and at the end they go like this you
know and there's that gesture of triumph
that goes along with that and everybody
rises in one instant and just claps like
mad it's like well why what are you
doing
what are you doing when you're doing
that right you can't even help it it
grabs you right in the core of your
being and you stand up and it's it's an
act of worship that's what it is and you
saw someone go beyond their perfection
into the domain of chaos and establish
order right in front of your eyes and
you're so thrilled about that you know
you're happy to be alive and everyone's
celebrating it all at the same time and
it's an absolutely amazing thing and
that's what well sometimes that's what
this represents and sometimes that's
what this represents and that's what
we're trying to get at because that's at
the pinnacle of the hierarchy right not
only are you doing what you should be
doing but you're doing it in a way that
increases the probability that you'll do
it better the next time you do it and
then you could say here's another thing
to think about along the same lines and
I know we haven't got that out of an
easy yet you tell your kids to play fair
right you say Norman it's not whether
not you win it's how you play the game
and you say that you don't really know
what you mean you feel kind of stupid
saying it even though you know it's true
and your kid looks at you like there's
something wrong with you because he
doesn't know what you're talking about
either but you know it's true and so
here's why it's true life isn't a game
it's a set of games and the rule is
never sacrifice victory across the set
of games for victory and
one game right and that's what it means
to play properly you want to play so
that people keep inviting you to play
because that's how you win right you win
by being invited to play the largest
possible array of games and the way you
do that is by manifesting the fact that
you can play in a reciprocal manner
every time you play even if there's
victory at stake and that's what makes
you successful across time and we all
know that and we even tell our kids that
but we don't know that we know it and so
we're not adapting ourselves to the game
and victory in the game we're adapting
ourselves to the metagame and victory
across the set of all possible games and
that's what that well that's exactly
what as far as I can tell that's exactly
what this is aiming at to that that's
the same idea that there's that there's
a transit there's a mode of being that
transcends the particularities of the of
the localized contests that's the other
way to think about it and to act morally
is not to win today's contest at the
expense of the rest of possible contests
and again I don't see that as something
that's arbitrary it's not relativistic
there's an absolute moral an absolute
moral stance there and everyone
recognizes it and and I also think it's
the key to success and I would also say
it's very much akin in a strange way
like the the the person who is the
master at being invited to play the
largest possible games number of games
is also the same person I haven't quite
figured out the precise relationship
between these two is also the same
person that goes out forthrightly to
conquer the unknown before it presents
itself as the enemy at the door they're
the same thing now I don't I can't
haven't figured well why that is exactly
but but well I'll figure it out
eventually and when I do I'll don't tell
you well if you're interested so okay so
here's the mother no ideas of God as as
hierarchical authority figures so strip
the religious preconceptions off what
you observe and just look at what you
see well look there's primate looking
upward ad dominance figure that's that's
what you see there now it's very
interestingly symbolically represented
because you have gone
the farther there with the cross and I
think what that means as far as I can
tell is that there's a recognition there
in the image that the person who's most
dominant is the one who's or the most
have the most authority is the one who's
voluntarily accepted the suffering
that's part of being and that's what
that picture represents it's like the
authority holds that says this is what
you have to accept and that that that
that transfix is the viewer because of
because of the fact that it's true and
you think well is that true okay well
think about it this way
do you like brave people or do you like
cowards well that that's pretty
straightforward and what's the ultimate
act of bravery it's to come to terms
with the fact that you're mortal and
limited and to live forthrightly
regardless well obviously that's at the
core of what's of what's admirable and
why would we presume that that's not the
case we act as if that's the case it's
what everyone dreams and wishes that
they could they could do I mean assuming
that you know you've dispensed with the
idea that you're going to be immortal I
suppose that might be worth wishing for
too or or perhaps not immortal is a very
long time but you certainly want this
and that image says well this is what
you should be and you know we've got
that same opening into the sky going on
in that image that I showed you before
it's like this is a transcendent truth
that constantly reman efest itself
across time and space and Jung would say
it's built into your psyche that image
now you know there are elements of it
that are culturally constructed it
wouldn't necessarily have to be the
cross
although the cross is a very old symbol
it's far older than then it's use in
Christianity it has been used in many
many religious representations but that
echoes the soul echoes with that you
know and well then there's Moses up
there on the on the Mount receiving
these the the law and so we'll talk a
lot more about that when we get to
Exodus but if yeah yeah yeah if we get
to Exodus so well look where does it
happen well on the mountain well that's
a pyramid that's up right that's optics
up it's it's up in
stratosphere is up in the sky where
where you look upward okay and and then
so what's happening to Moses well here
here's a bit of a clue as far as I can
tell I figured this out partly again by
reading Jean Piaget because one of the
things that PSA said about kids was that
they first learned to play a game but
they don't know what the rules are
meaning that if you have a bunch of kids
together they can play a game but if you
take one of the kids out of the game
when they're young say six and you say
what the rule are what are the rules
they can only sort of give you a
representation so you take six-year-old
one and he'll tell you some of the rules
and six-year-old two will tell you
different rules and and you know
six-year-old three will tell you
different rules but if you put them all
together they can play so they have the
knowledge embodied either individually
or in the group the knowledge is there
to be extracted well then they get a
little older they can extract the rules
and then they start to play by the rules
and then the CSA's last step was well
they didn't just the kids play by the
rules that they learned that they can
make the rules and he thought about that
as moral progression first you can play
then you can play by the rules then you
learn maybe because he didn't think
everyone learned this that you're
actually the master of the rules that
doesn't mean the rules are arbitrary but
it means that you could be the generator
of the rule that's assuming that you
know how to play the game and he thought
about that as a moral moral progression
and then I thought well that's exactly
what happened to Moses in in the story
of Exodus because Moses is out there
leading all those Israelites around and
like they don't have a law they don't
have a lawgiver
they have a tradition and they're all
like crabby because both are in a desert
it's like they're in a tyranny but now
they're in a desert it's like that's no
improvement so they're really getting
pretty about it and so they're
worshipping false idols and having one
catastrophe after another and they get
Moses to judge their conflicts so he
does that for god only knows how long
forever crabby Israelites come to Moses
and at him it's like wow he did
this and she did that and and so then he
has to figure out how to make peace and
he does that so long that one of his I
think it's his father-in-law tells him
he has to stop doing it because he's
going to exhaust himself well then you
think well what's happening well and I'm
not assuming that this is a like a
literal
historical story I think again it's a
condensation well any group has a set of
customs just like a wolf pack does and
so then the customs are being manifest
in someone who's a genius is watching
and thinking okay well what's the rule
in this situation what's the rule in
this situation what's the rule in this
situation and then in his imagination
the rules turn into a hierarchy and then
he goes up on the mountain just bang and
he thinks oh my god here's the rules
that we've been living by all this time
and that's the revelation of the
commandments well and you think well how
else could it be you think the rules
came first and baying them came second
it's like no the rules come first sorry
the actions come first the obeying them
comes first and then you figure out what
everybody's up to you say hey look this
is what you've been up to all along
everybody goes oh yeah that seems to
make sense peak and if it didn't who
would follow them no one was going to
follow them if they don't match what's
already there you just think about that
is unjust and so that's that's portrayed
here as a cataclysmic human event it's
like oh my god we've been chimpanzees
we've been in this hierarchy of
authority for so long we have no idea
what we're doing and all of a sudden
poof it bursts into revelatory
consciousness and we could say here is
the law and you say well is it given by
God well hey it depends on what you mean
by God we could start with that
presupposition but it's not like it just
came out of nowhere it took it and this
is something else Nietzsche observed so
interestingly and he said you know that
a moral revelation was the consequence
of a tremendously long process of
initial construction and then
formulation thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of years of
custom a building custom before you get
the revelation of the articulated law
and that's a description of the pattern
that works let's say well what's the
pattern that works it's the game that
you can play with everybody else
day after day with no degeneration and
that's another thing Piaget figured out
it's so brilliant and that's his idea of
the equilibrate state it's an extension
of the menu' accounts idea about the
universe
maksim right act in a way so that each
action could become a universal rule
that was kinda mental moral Maxim and
PSA put a twist on that he said no no
that's not exactly yet it's act in such
a way that it works for you now and next
week and next month and next year and
ten years from now and so that while
it's working for you it's also working
for the people around you and for the
broader society and then and that's the
equilibrate estate and you could think
about that as an intimation of the
kingdom of the City of God on earth it's
something like that and it's based on
this idea that a morality has to be
iterable and you know there's lots of
there's been lots of simulations online
already artificial intelligence
simulations of trading games right I
mean the people who've been studying the
emergence of moral behavior say in
artificial intelligence systems have
already caught on to the idea that one
of the crucial elements to the analysis
of morality is inner ability
you can't play a degenerating game
because because it degenerates like
obviously you want to play a game that
at least remains stable across time and
God if you could really get your act
together maybe it would slowly get
better and of course that's what you'd
hope for your family right that's what
you're always trying to do unless you're
completely hell-bent on revenge and
destruction it's like is there a way
that we can continue to play together
that will make playing together even
better the next day that's what you're
up to and well I don't see anything
arbitrary about that and part of it this
is also why I think that bloody post
modernists are so incorrect because you
know they say something like there's an
infinite number of interpretations of
the world and that's actually true
but then they make a mistake and they
say well no interpretation is to be
privileged over any other interpretation
it's like wrong wrong that's that's
where things go seriously off the rails
because the interpretation has to be and
this is the piagetian objection is like
if you and i are going to play a game
rule one is we both have to want to play
rule two is other people are going to
let us play rule 3 is we should be able
to play it across a pretty long period
of time without it degenerating and
maybe rule 4 is well we're playing the
world
shouldn't kill us it's like there are
not very many gay like you don't send
your kids out to play on the
superhighway right so they're not
playing hockey on the superhighway
because the world kills them and so
there's an infinite number of
interpretations but there is not an
infinite number of solutions and the
solutions are constrained by the fact of
the world and are suffering in the world
and then also constrained by the fact
that we constrain each other and so
that's that's where I think that's gone
like dreadfully dreadfully wrong so all
right it's really fun to look at these
old pictures once you kind of know what
they mean
you know the leaf that's what I've
discovered is that once I kind of
understand the underlying rationale for
I mean someone worked hard on that
that's an engraving right they took a
long time making that picture they're
serious about it and when you understand
what it means you know all those people
there their prostate prostrate at the at
the at the revelation of the law
it's like well no wonder it's like break
the law and see what happens breaks the
universal moral law man and see what
happens you know I see people in that
situation well as you all do all the
time perhaps me more than you because
I'm a clinical psychologist you know and
if the people I'm seeing haven't broken
the universal law then you can bloody
well be sure that people around them
have it's no joke like you make a
mistake and things will go seriously
wrong for you and so it's no wonder that
you'd be terrified at the revelation of
the structure that governs our being one
of the things that's so remarkable about
the old testament this is another thing
needs to comment a dog he was a real
admirer of the Old Testament not so much
of the New Testament he thought it was a
sin for Europe to have glued the New
Testament on to the Old Testament
because he thought the Old Testament was
a really accurate representation of the
phenomenology of ba it's like stay awake
speak properly be honest or watch the
hell out because things will come your
way that you just do not want to see at
all and it might not just be you it
might be everyone you know and
everything
about your culture that is demolished
for for generation after generation it's
like stay awake and be careful and I
like I think that people only don't
believe that when they're being
hubristic and I think that most people
know that deep in their hearts you know
when you get high on your horse that
happens fairly often if you have any
sense you think geez I better be careful
top myself down and fare a bit because
if I get too puffed up man something's
going to come along and take me out at
the knees and everyone knows that pride
comes before a fall it's like if you
have any that's why it says in the Old
Testament that fear of God is the
beginning of wisdom it's like I've never
in all my years as a clinical
psychologist and this is something that
really does terrify me I have I have
never seen anyone ever get away with
anything at all even once you know
there's that old idea that God has a
book you know and keeps track of
everything in heaven it's like okay okay
you know maybe it's not a book fine but
that is a really useful thing to think
about because well maybe you disagree
maybe you think people get away with
things all the time I tell you I've
never seen it what I see instead is that
thing happens right they someone twists
the fabric of reality and they do it
successfully because it doesn't snap
back at them that moment and then like
two years later something unravels and
they get walloped and they think oh my
god that's so unfair and then we track
it it's like but what happened before
that this and then what this and then
what this and then what oh oh this well
that's where it went wrong it's yeah
because you can't twist the fabric of
reality without having it snap back it
doesn't work that way and why would it
because what are you going to do twist
the fabric of reality I don't think so I
think it's bigger than you you know and
I think that one of the things that
really tempts people is the idea that
well I can get away with it it's like
yeah you try you see oh well that works
it's like you get away with nothing and
that is the beginning of wisdom and I
it's something that deeply terrifies me
and you know err ever since last
September when I came to board like
broader public attention one of the
thing I'd be terrified of making mistake
because I certainly know I'm more than
capable of making a mistake and
going so far either I haven't made one
or no one found out about it
so but it's like you know we walk on a
very thin and narrow edge and we're very
lucky when things aren't degenerating
into chaos around us or rapidly moving
too far too much order and it's not an
easy thing to stay on that line and you
can tell when you say you're on that
line because the things are deeply
meaningful and engaging when you're on
that line but if you're not
existentially terrified about the
consequences of wavering off that then
you are truly not awake so and that's
what I see in this picture you know it's
like look out man
because there are rules and if you break
them god help you
[Music]
so one of the things that seems to me
the case with regard this in the
question period a bit last time is that
one of the things that seems to be
actually one of the advantages to gluing
the New Testament on to the Old
Testament is the idea of a
transformation and morality that is
analogous to the PIA jetty an idea that
after you learn to play by the rules you
can learn to make the rules because I
think that's actually what happens to
some degree in the transition between
the Old Testament and the New Testament
because in the Old Testament most
morality is prohibition here are things
you shouldn't do it's like no fair
enough that's a lot of what you do with
your kids don't do this don't do this
don't especially when they're happy
you're always going around telling them
to stop being so happy because all
they're doing is causing trouble it's
quite painful if you're a parent and you
notice that but the first morality is
prohibition right control yourself so
you don't cause too much trouble and
then maybe if you get that down and
you're good at it then the next thing is
well once you're disciplined then you
can start working toward something
that's a positive good and that's the
transformation that seems to me to be
fundamentally characteristic of the
juxtaposition of the New Testament on to
the Old Testament but in these images is
still something like serve tradition
serve the father psychologically
speaking support the tradition because
you live on it they're in an old
Mesopotamian story the enumeration
you can which you can read about if
you're interested in the original gods
who are really badly behaved they're
like two year old in fact they're a lot
like two year olds they kill the
primordial gone absolute pea tree Oracle
God they kill him and try to live on his
corpse well that's what we all do right
because we live on the corpse of our
ancestors you could say we live on the
corpse of our culture it's dead and
that's not a great place to live so you
have to keep revivifying it so the damn
thing you know stays active and awake
you you stay on the carbs for too long
and then the devil or the demon of chaos
comes back and that's what happens in
the Mesopotamian story it's like don't
be thinking that you can stay on the
corpse of your ancestors for too long
without contributing to the
revivification of the system because the
chaos that all of that holds that that
all that holds that bay will definitely
come and visit you you see that in
stories like The Hobbit
you know hobbits they're nice they like
to eat they're kind of fat they're
shorts are not very bright you know
they're hubristic they have no idea
what's out there in the broader world
they're protected if you remember by the
Striders who are the sons of great kings
who look like tramps they have nothing
but contempt for them they patrol the
borders and keep the bloody hobbits safe
but out there out there in the periphery
all hell is brewing and chaos is is is
generating and forming and that's an
archetypal story and that's why people
like that story so much because that's
exactly right like we're the hobbits and
there are we are protected from chaos by
the spirits of our dead ancestors and
we're too damn stupid to know it and we
think oh well we don't need them anymore
and that to me that's post-modernism
that's what the bloody universities are
doing with the humanities to absolutely
appalling and we will pay for it so
unless we wake up and hopefully we'll
wake up because that would be better
than paying for it even though being
awake as well they're painful so so then
I had this vision one time and I kind of
portrayed it in this in this image of
what the world was like and I thought
well it's not a pyramid it's not a
single hierarchy of authority that's not
what it is it's it's an array of
hierarchies of authority so you imagine
this sort of infinite plane and the
the infinite plane there's nothing but
pyramids and inside the pyramids there
are strata of people everywhere far as
you can look some of the pyramids are
tall some of them are short they overlap
it's endless the plain is endless and
those are all the positions to which you
could rise and everybody's inside the
pyramid sort of crammed up trying to
move towards the top and then there's
the possibility of sailing across over
top of all of them and seeing how the
structure itself works and that's and
that's the eye that floats above the
pyramid and it sees the structure itself
and the highest order of being is not to
be at the top of the pyramid it's to use
the discipline that you attain by
striving towards the top of the pyramid
to release yourself from the pyramid and
move one step up and that's I think
that's one of the things that's
instantiated in the idea of the for
example of the Holy Ghost so and I think
that's akin to that that's Sisyphus and
needs a set of Sisyphus if I remember
correctly that one has to imagine him
happy well if there's a rock at the
bottom of the hill then you might as
well push it up the hill and if it rolls
back down well then you've got something
else to do don't you can push the damn
rock back up the hill and there's no
shortage of rocks to put up to push up
the hill and that's what we're built for
anyways and so let's go out and like
push some damn boulders up the hill and
then maybe we could have enough
self-confidence and enough enough
respect for ourselves that we wouldn't
have to turn to hatred and revenge and
try to take everything down because I
think that's the alternative so he's not
weak that's one thing you can say about
him the same idea represented there
right that's outlets who voluntarily
takes the world on his shoulders it's
like the idea of Christ
taking the sins of the world on his
shoulders it's exactly the same notion
which is the notion that you should be
able to recognize in yourself all the
horror of humanity and take
responsibility for it because that's
what that means and the thing that's so
interesting about that is that if you
can recognize yourself in yourself all
the horror of humanity you will
instantly have a hell of a lot more
respect for yourself than you did before
you did that because there's some real
utility and knowing that you're a
monster now on just because you're a
monster doesn't mean you have to be a
monster but it's really useful to know
that
you are one so then and one of the
things that you knew and this is
something that I find so amazing about
his writing is I think something that
really distinguishes him for example
from Joseph Campbell who talked about
following your bliss is like Jung said
very clearly that the first step to
enlightenment is the encounter with the
shadow and what he meant by that was
everything horrible that human beings
have done was done by human beings and
you're one of them and so if you don't
understand that and to understand that
really means to know how it was that you
could have done it and that's a
shattering thing to try to imagine that
to try to imagine yourself as someone
who's engaged in medieval torture to see
how you could in fact do that you're
never the same after you learn that
but being never the same after learning
that is unbelievably useful because when
you understand that that's what you're
like then you're a whole different
creature and I don't think and this is
something I did learn from Jung is that
you cannot be a good person until you
know how much evil you contain within
you it is not possible and it's partly
because you just don't have any potency
like if you're just naive if you're just
nice if you'd never hurt anyone you'd
never hurt a fly you don't have the
capability for any of that why would
anyone ever take you seriously you're
you're just you're a domestic animal at
best you know and a rather contemptible
one at that and it's a very strange
thing because you wouldn't think that
the revelation of the capacity for evil
is a precondition for the realization of
good but I believe first of all why
would you be serious enough to even
attempt to pursue the good unless you
had some sense of what the consequence
was of not doing it you have to be
serious about these sorts of things it's
not it's not it's not the game of a
child right it's the game of a fully
developed adult and you have learned
this in part when I had little kids I
wrote a chapter from my new book called
never let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them and why was that
and I read I read that wrote that after
I knew I was a monster and I thought I'm
going to make sure I liked my kids I'm
going to make sure they behave around me
so that I like them because I'm Way
bigger than them and I'm Way more cruel
than they are and I've got tricks up my
sleeve
that they cannot even possibly imagine
and if if they irritate me I will
absolutely take it out on them and if
you don't think that you're the sort of
person that would do that then you are
the sort of person who is doing it you
know we're not going to get that amenity
ha ha aria I watched this great
documentary once called Hitman Hart and
was about Bret Hart and who was the most
famous Canadian in the world for a while
and he was a worldwide Wrestling
Federation wrestler you know and he was
a good guy and he came from this famous
family of wrestlers who all came from
Alberta I think there were seven
brothers who were wrestlers and seven
sisters and all the sisters married
wrestlers and they were all offspring
children of Stu Hart who was a wrestling
impresario like 40 years ago and it was
it was such a cool documentary because I
was always wondering why in the world
did people watch wrestling and and then
believe it you know
believe it do you believe movies when
you go watch them it's like that's a
hard question to answer while you're
there you do and so if you're watching
wrestling and you're a wrestling fan do
you believe it well it is a matter of
belief it's a matter of being engaged in
a drama and there are different levels
of drama right so let's say worldwide
Wrestling Federation drama is not the
most sophisticated form of drama okay
but I'm not being a not being a smart
aleck when I'm saying that there is
drama of different sophistication for
different people and that's also why
religious truths exist at multiple
levels simultaneously right it is got to
be something in it for everyone and
that's a hard belief system that's a
hard system to put together something
for the unbelievably sophisticated and
something for the common person
okay so we have wrestling and Bret Hart
was a good guy and he fell into the
archetype of being a good guy and that's
partly what the what the story's about
it was a bit too much for him but um one
of the things that he he laid out so
carefully where
because he figured that 120 million
people knew him something like that and
that everywhere he went he was treated
like a hero and he found out quite a bit
of quite a burden as you could imagine
if you think about it but he portrayed
what was happening in the wrestling ring
as classic good against evil but not
conceptualized and discussed right
embodied thought out acted out you know
like like the like Thor and the Hulk
except like right in front of you and so
well that's exactly this sort of thing I
mean we could consider hockey more
sophisticated than wrestling perhaps and
as I said I'm not being a critic of
these I'm not being critically minded
about these things I understand their
purpose and I would highly recommend
that documentary it's a brilliant
documentary but this is it's the same
thing it's a silver cup right it's like
there's the hero of the team that's the
hero of the team's you know here's
something cool if you're the fan of the
Toronto Blue Jays are the Toronto Maple
Leafs of course this hardly ever happens
to you if you're the fan of the Toronto
Maple Leafs because they always lose but
haha but but if you're watching a game
and your team wins and we take your
testosterone levels then they went up
and if you watch the Toronto Maple Leafs
and they lost and you're a fan then your
testosterone levels go down so that's
pretty damn funny you know I mean really
don't you see how deeply instantiated
this is in people I mean it bloody well
alters your biochemistry like your your
your testosterone levels it's all more
my team loss you know it's like ah do we
know there'll be nothing in it for the
wife tonight you know
yeah well this is the cosmos I think
from from the phenomenological
perspective and one of the things that
that that has come to my realization is
that this is real this is real it's not
a metaphor it's way deeper than a
metaphor the most real things about life
are the place you don't know and the
place you know and you could say well
that's explored territory and unexplored
territory that's real and it's been
around forever
back to the lobsters you know if you put
lobsters in their new place the first
thing they do is go around their
territory finding places to hide and
also making a burrow so the first thing
they do is establish what they know
against what they don't know and that's
real it's real from the Darwinian
perspective and we're going to say that
what's real from the Darwinian
perspective is plenty real enough
because we're alive and everything and
so that sort of thing matters like well
that's what this is the Taoist symbol
that's what it says is that what way it
says what is experience made of
eternally that's easy chaos and order
and in every bit of chaos there's the
possibility of order and in every bit of
order there's the possibility of chaos
and that's the way right that's the path
of life that's life itself and where
you're supposed to be is right on the
border between the two of those and why
is that stable enough engaged enough
right so not only are you doing what you
should be doing you're doing in a way
that increases the probability that
you'll do it better tomorrow and you can
tell when you're doing that because
you're engaged you're in the right time
and place and your your neurology tells
you that that's what meaning is that's
what transcendent meaning is and that's
so cool because I also think that that
is the antidote to existential suffering
the antidote to existential suffering is
to be at the right place at the right
time and you know you want to get
technical about it okay anxiety and pain
that's the cause that's the reality of
the existential
so suffering okay so let's say you're in
the right place at the right time what
happens to you biochemically
dopaminergic activation what does that
do
suppresses anxiety and it's analgesic
now it's more than that because also
produces positive emotion and the desire
to move forward and it underlies
creativity and and so so not only do you
get the positive engagement from a
neurochemical perspective you get the
analgesia and you get the anti end and
you get the reduction of anxiety so it's
not hypothetical it's and it is the case
that the dopaminergic systems those are
the exploratory systems unbelievably
ancient and archaic are activated when
you're optimally positioned to be to be
what incorporating new information which
is what human beings do because we're
information foragers and so we want to
be secure but building on our security
at the same time and then we want to do
it for ourselves we want to do it for
other people we want to do it for our
families we want to do it for broader
society we want to bring the whole world
together in alignment to do that and
that's meaningful and god only knows
what we could do about the suffering of
the world if we did that you know we
have no idea what we could do if we
started doing things properly and maybe
so many of the things that dismay us
about life we could we could stop I mean
we stopped a lot of them in the last
hundred years you know things are a lot
better than they were a hundred years
ago obviously they're not perfect but a
hundred years ago 120 years ago man you
know the average person in the Western
world lived on less than a dollar a day
in today's dollars it's like you just
try that for a week and see how much fun
that is so the Daoists well what is this
well this is the pre cosmogonic chaos
out of which the Word of God extracted
habitable order at the beginning of time
it's the same thing it's the same thing
and that chaos
we'll talk a bit more about that later I
guess because it's a very complicated
thing to to describe but it's certainly
the thing that when you encounter the
chaos is what you encounter when the
Twin Towers fall right you remember what
that was like right so it was it was
September 10th well that was the world
everyone knew what the world was like
and then it was September 11th and
everyone walked around day
for three days because the building's
failed but so what you can see a
building fall you can understand what
it's what happens when a building falls
so then what's going on with the being
dazed well it's the chaos that underlies
our how to the Lord have manifested
itself in those buildings collapse was a
brilliant act of terrorism and everyone
was frozen and curious because that's
how we react to that sort of thing the
it's like it's like the shark you know
remember that famous that famous movie
poster for Jaws with the woman swimming
on the top of the water and that
terrible Leviathan shark underneath
coming up to to take her out well that's
life man that's the world and now and
then you see that and when something
Falls like the Twin Towers fall you
remember that the ocean below you the
abyss right the primordial abyss that
bloody thing is deep and then you're
fragile and that happens when someone
betrays you and it's happened it happens
to you when your dreams fall apart you
encounter that chaos again from which
the world is extracted and then you're
called upon to act out attention and the
word in order to bring the world back
into order and none of that is none of
that is superstitious none of that is
superstitious none of that's even
metaphorical it's real its ribs more
real than anything else and I think the
reason for that in part is that this has
been it's been this way forever right as
long as there's been life this has been
the rule of life and that's the cosmos
that's reality that's what we inhabit
and so one of the things you know the
the so-called New Atheists and I they
don't want to go on a tangent about New
Atheists because I think atheists are
often remarkably honest and very
consistent in their analysis so but I
just don't think they're taking the
problem seriously that like I don't
think they take their evolutionary
theorizing nearly with the seriousness
that it that it necessitates and I don't
think that I don't think that you can
dispute the proposition that the longer
something has had a selection effect
life the more real it is it's the
fundamental axiom of Darwinian biology
and I think the Darwinian world is more
real than the physical world that was
the argument that I was trying to have
with with Sam Harris and I didn't do the
world's best job with that although it
went not too bad the second time but
it's it's not something to be taken
lightly it's a very serious profound and
meaningful proposition and people act it
out and want to act it out whether they
know it or not that's Marduk so the
story of Marduk I'll just give it to you
very briefly time at an apse who are
locked in embrace at the beginning of
time goddess of saltwater God of
freshwater together
chaos an order right they give rise
masculine feminine they give rise to the
world of the elder gods and those are to
me their primordial motivational forces
or something like that and their rage
and their lust and their love and all
these things that possess us that are
there forever and they're out in the
world acting and they carelessly slay
absolu their father and they're making a
racket and then they collapse ooh and
then time at gives wind of that and
that's a timeout right there by the way
she's kind of a rough looking creature
and she's a mother of all things and so
she's not very happy about this they
said though these her children have
destroyed structure itself plus they're
noisy and careless and so she thinks all
right just like Noah just like the God
that brings the flood to know what
exactly the same idea time ad comes back
it says yeah okay enough is enough I'm
going to take you out and she makes this
battalion of monsters and puts the worst
monster there is at the head of the
battalion his name is king he's like a
precursor to the idea of Satan and she
lets the gods know hey I'm coming for
you and so they're not very happy about
this because their gods but like yeah
she's chaos itself right she gave birth
to everything this is no joke and so
they send one God out after another to
confront her and they all come back with
the tails between their legs there's no
hope and then one day there's a new God
that emerges in that
Marduk and the gods know as soon as he
pops up they know he's something new
remember and this is happening while the
Mesopotamians are assembling themselves
into one of the world's first great
civilizations so all the gods of all
those tribes are coming together to
organize themselves into a hierarchy to
figure out what proposition rules
everything and so Marduk is elected by
all the gods and he says look I'll go
out there and I'll take on time at but
here's the rule from here on you follow
me I determine destiny I'm the top god
I'm the thing at the top of the
hierarchy and all the other gods say hey
look no problem you get rid of chaos we
do exactly what you say now Marduk he
has eyes all the way around his head and
he speaks magic words
those are his primary attributes and so
he takes a net and he goes out to
confront time out and and he he he
encloses her in a net which i think is
so cool because it's an encapsulation
right it's a conceptual encapsulation he
encloses chaos itself in a conceptual
structure he puts it in the net and then
he cuts her into pieces and he makes the
world and then then he creates human
beings to inhabit that world and to
serve the gods and he creates human
beings out of the blood of king of the
worst of the demons and that took me to
call into young as the student might
help me figure that out I thought that's
pretty damn pessimistic it's like you
know what exactly it sounds like a fall
metaphor it's like the idea of original
sin but but our joint conclusion with
regards to that with it human beings are
the only creatures in creation that can
truly deceive right we have the capacity
for evil just like it says in the Adam
and Eve story we can actually do that
and that's why we're made out of the
blood of king of the king of the demons
the we are the thing that can deceive
that can twist the structure of reality
well so Marduk now the Mesopotamians had
an emperor right
and the emperor was the avatar of Marduk
that's what made him Emperor he was only
at Emperor if he was going to be Marduk
he had to be a good Marduk which Mantia
do confront time at chaos and cut her
off and make or
out of her pieces and what the method
name is used to do at the New Year's
celebration they go outside the walled
city and that's explored territory
versus unexplored territory they go
outside their walled city into chaos and
they bring all the statues that
represented the gods and they'd act this
out because they're trying to figure
something out right you're trying to
figure out what this means they're
acting it out and then they take their
Emperor and the priest would make them
kneel and they'd take all his king
equally all his king uniform off his
Emperor uniform off and make him kneel
and humiliate him and nail him with a
glove and say okay how were you not a
good Marduk this year right and then
he'd recount all the ways that he was
inadequate in confronting chaos and then
they do the celebration and Marduk would
win and and the king would go sleep with
a royal prostitute and and the reason
for that was it's the same idea st.
George pulling the Virgin from the
dragon it's exactly the same idea that
if you call if you encounter the
reptilian chaos you can extract
something out of it with which if you
unite you produce creative order that's
what they were acting out and that was
the basis for the Mesopotamian idea of
sovereignty it's so smart it's so
unbelievably smart and you know the
Mesopotamians had a massive influence on
the civilizations that then had a
massive influence on assets one of the
stories of how the notion of sovereignty
itself came to be it's the evolution of
the idea of God that's one way of
thinking about it but even more
importantly it's the evolution of the
idea of the redemptive human being right
and that's taken - it's one of its
conclusions following the story of
Buddha but also in the story of Christ
the idea of the perfect individual and
the notion is well that's the word that
speaks truth into chaos at the beginning
of time to generate habitable order that
is good that's the story and so with
that
let's see oh sure I'll just show you
these pictures because they're so
interesting once you know what they mean
they're so cool that's a symbol of
infinity
let's Hercules and Hydra what's life
like cut off one head what happens seven
more grow right what do you do run hold
well no that's not what you do it this
is what you do you fight it it's the
it's the chaos that generates partial
chaos it's the ultimate chaos that
generates partial chaos but that chaos
also is what revista finds life because
otherwise it would just be static
mercury the head of the Hydra right
freeze of you I'd Saint George he's
doing it peacefully which is so
interesting right he's got a beatific
look on his face in that particular
representation another Saint George
right the Virgin in the background I
think that's say Dan if I remember
correctly st. George is the patron saint
of England here's an interesting one
this actually sheds light on on the
human proclivity for warfare st. George
that's a Muslim soldier it's really easy
to transform the enemy into the dragon
right because the enemy is often the
predator and we do that instantaneously
right without a second thought and so
then we can go to war morally because
why not take out the snakes well you
know the problem is where are the snakes
or maybe they're outside and maybe
they're not maybe they're in this room
and even worse maybe they're in you and
that's wisdom when you know that their
review why wouldn't she be happy about
that especially if she had a especially
if she had a child right seriously
and that's horace right the god of
vision and he was a he was a Falken
because falcons have great vision and
they fly above everything and they can
see everything so that was the Egyptian
created god Horus and I'll tell you the
story about Horus at some points well
now here are some pictures that
demonstrate what I had described as the
emergence of let's say the meta hero out
of the hero so there's the person you
admire and then there's the set of
people that you admire and then there's
the meta set of admirable people and the
extraction of that ideal as far as I can
tell that's just what's portrayed in
these images that's a great one it's
very sophisticated image you see that
the two sides of Christ's face are not
symmetrical one is God in ones man
that's what that icon means and so the
fully developed person in this
representation it's one of the oldest
representations of this sort that we
know the idea is that there's a there's
a human person in his ordinariness let's
say and then there's this this kinship
with the divine that's associated with
the willing adoption of the
responsibilities of moral mortal being
and that produces this union and then
it's manifest in a book right because
that's speech and it's associated with
the son right it's the proper way of
being and that's a perfect example I
think of the emergence of the archetype
out of the multitude that's what it
looks like to me
and so I guess now we're done with
Genesis one and took three lectures but
God's complicated you know that's the
thing so
[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you and next week by all
appearances that's where we are so we've
got 20 minutes for questions so in the
past I've done some work with blog Big
Brother Big Sister and whatever that
being said that the most common story I
tend to hear from Pacific youth is that
they write they're raised in a single
family home usually with a mom daddy's
there on a picture in alcoholic whatever
whatever the writer so we have this
child who is trying to seek ways to make
himself healthy and empower himself in a
ways that a healthy father should have
done so you know between the formative
years of like 1 to 4 so I think you know
I'm going with this how let's say for
someone who born without like a good
father figure where would they go out in
the world or like what for series of
incidents where they try to expose
themselves to to like gain access to
that balancing of health and knowledge
that a father though a good father
figure should have provided to in the
first place
ok well partly I mean certainly to some
degree a good mother can provide that
right to some degree although it's hard
for one person to be everything right
you know and I think one of the
conundrums that face women and this is a
tough one and this is why I think women
are higher in trade agreeableness and
higher and trade negative emotion is
that you know the primary problem that a
woman has with an infant is why not
throw it out a window because it's very
annoying right I mean it's there all the
time it's constant demand it's
absolutely constant amount tremendous
dependency and so a woman has to be
tilted towards mercy that's how it looks
to me right and especially during it's
so important during the especially the
first year when children are so
unbelievably vulnerable and so I think
it's very difficult for women to be
merciful like that and to make the shift
to encouraging disciplinarian I think
that's a very difficult thing for people
to do simultaneously although you know
people people I'm not saying that women
are always only merciful and men are
always only encouraging disciplinarians
but things do sort themselves out to
some degree like that and I think also
the biochemical transformations that
accompany pregnancy and childbirth and
lactation also tilt a mother towards
that as well we have to really love that
little thing right
it's it's number one no matter what it
demands and then telling it what to do
and making sure it's behaving properly
that's that's a whole different issue
now but the kids who lack fathers I mean
first of all they can find that to some
degree in their friends and that's often
what father boys do in particular they
go into gangs and they generate the
missing men masculinity in the game well
that's not so good because like what the
hell do they know well they don't know
anything right they're just stupid kids
and they're like fifteen years old and
the testosterone is pumping and they're
trying to get the hell away from their
mother which is what they're supposed to
do and and they're not in the right
position to exercise any authority over
themselves so that's that's not good
they can find it in education they can
find it in books they can find it in
movies they can find it in sports heroes
and so forth because the image of the
father is fragmented and distributed
among the community but it's very very
difficult to not have a father right and
you know one of the things that we're
doing in our society which i think is I
think it's absolutely appalling is that
we're making the case that all families
are equal it's like sorry no wrong then
there's no empirical data supporting
that proposition by the way it's much
better for kids to have two parents know
who those parents are that's a whole
different issue okay and if I could just
add one more thing of how would you ask
that question so let's see a daughter
was raised not a father because she
would all see have different ways to
find those fragments of her missing
father than like a boy would instead
because obviously they're raised
differently at least they should have
been well I think it's the same issue
you know I mean I think that another
danger that emerges mrs. Freud's of
course famous observation is that you
know if there's mom and child were
father and child that relationship can
get a little closer than it should and
then the lines get blurry and mixed and
I'm not saying that that happens to
everyone obviously but but it's still a
danger that that's inherent in the
situation they're thrust together too
tightly without sufficient resources and
so the responsibility has to be
distributed more and like I really do
think that it's the sign of the
degeneration of the society when that
when when single parenthood becomes
anything approximating the norm it's not
a good idea
then the and part of the reason I
believe that and I think this has to do
with the
overwhelming selfishness of modern life
is that marriage isn't for the people
who are married it's for the children
obviously and like if you can't handle
that grow the hell up
see right now I mean seriously yeah
seriously
thank you once you once you have kids it
is not about you period
now that doesn't mean it isn't about you
at all but that just seems so
self-evident to me I can't believe that
anybody would even would even question
it
oh it's Dino Larson oh yes well I'm
certainly aware of that yes it's
questioned it's almost illegal to
question it now you know to to or
illegal to make the set of propositions
that I'm making so that's the best I can
do guys excellent thank you
the question is going in part two the
first part of first up here lecture but
it's also something that's been on my
mind listening to your lectures over the
past few months and that's when we talk
about the psychological truth or
significance of the Bible to what extent
does that psychological psychological
truth has to be embodied in specific
historical events or people and so for
instance the thing that sort of been
bugging on my mind there's there's a
part that st. Paul is talking about in
the New Testament somewhere in one of
his letters and he's talking to the
resurrection and he says if it didn't
happen then if this whole thing just
means the faith is meaningless like for
him there had to be that embodiment of
that his capital yes the nor event in
that case well the best answer I have to
that at the moment is that I'm really
happy that I'm not at that point yet in
this lecture series
you know because because that there's a
there's a crucial issue there and I
don't know exactly what to make of it
and my approach at the moment as I said
is to approach this as rationally as I
possibly can and I hope I know a hell of
a lot more about what I'm doing by the
time I get to that particular question
and I do have the beginnings of ways to
answer that but I'm not going to answer
that at all right now because it's so
bloody complicated that would just burn
me to a frazzle and I'm already mostly
bird to a frazzle after that lecture so
I couldn't attempt to even start to
sketch it out I don't know I mean part
of it is to be just rational about it
just to be rational about it there is
something about the idea that continual
death and rebirth is a necessary
precondition to proper human adaptation
every time you learn something new
that's important part of the stupid old
you has to die and sometimes that can be
an awful lot of you and in fact it can
be so much of you sometimes that you
just die right you just can't handle it
and so there is there is a real idea
that you have to identify with the part
of yourself that transcends your current
personality that can constantly die and
be reborn now then I could say well that
means that all of this is psychological
and symbolic and that's the simplest
answer but I'm not satisfied with that
answer even though I think it's coherent
and complete because the world is a very
weird place and there are things about
it that we don't understand so so I
can't go I can't go any farther than
that at the moment so yeah hi dr.
Peterson
I just recently watched one of your
videos of you debating with
transgendered protesters at UofT free
speech rally in October and one of the
protesters one of the comments one of
the protesters said to you which isn't
particularly very like very chilling was
why do you have the right to determine
whether an individual is worthy of you
using their pronouns the scary thing to
me is how common this type of view
is among radical left-wing protesters on
University campuses who feel they have
the right to tell other people what they
can think what words they can use and
what speakers they can or cannot listen
to the even scarier part is that our
government is creating legislations to
back up their ADL ideologies which is
evident through Bill c16 m103 and bill
89 so my question is what do you think
the endgame is in all this because it
seems every year or we're in the process
of finding that out you know and I'm
sorry I'm sorry okay we're in the
process of finding that out I don't I
mean I think the endgame that underlies
all of that in my estimation is best
summed up by Jacques Derrida's
Christiane her criticism of Western
civilization its FAL logo centric now
we've already talked about what the
logos means right and so and and so for
for Derrida that was a sign of its utter
what would you call it
utter despit the dot early despicable
dominant nature of Western culture well
that that's what animates the post
modernists now they may not know that
because an indie ology gets fragmented
across its adherents and then it only
acts as the coherent ideology with all
those adherents come together in a mob
and then you see the animating spirit so
I said I think that there's a battle
going on that's a battle exactly at the
level that Derrida described and that's
a theological battle with a
philosophical with it with the
philosophical implications and out of
those philosophical implications come
political implications but it's not
primarily political and it's not
primarily philosophical it's deeper than
that and the post modernists are out
there their criticism was designed to be
fundamental and it also emerged out of
Marxism and let's not forget that the
Marxist criticism was not only
fundamental but just about resulted in
the nuclear annihilation of the
girl these are not trivial issues and
we're back in the same insane boat and
so what do I think should be done about
that well I thought about that way
before any of this happened and I think
that what we should do about it is we
should tell the truth because there
isn't anything more powerful than that
and that's the right theological answer
because the spoken truth brings good
into being well that's the FAL logo
centric idea and I'm trying to revisit
that to explain to people what it means
and to see if they think that's a good
idea I mean that's what we have to
figure out is it is that an idea worth
adhering to or not the alternative is
the c4 the post modernists the world is
that landscape of pyramids that I
described but there's no transcendent
vision that's over above that and all of
those pyramids are equally valid and
it's a war of everyone against everyone
it's like it's like the nightmare of
Hobbes Thomas Hobbes except that it's
not individuals it's groups and
everyone's that group you're a group
you're whatever your group is it's like
that's death as far as I'm concerned
it's it's it's utterly reprehensible and
and we better sort it out because if we
don't sort it out we are bloody well
going to pay for it
so thank you
[Applause]
hey how's it going I just want to say
thank you for doing all this and I
really appreciate that's Bob and Doug
McKenzie right yeah hey how's it going
yeah I'm glad you caught that yeah yeah
yeah well I did a Facebook poll yeah
people who are familiar with where your
work and a question kind of rose to the
top like just right out of their lives
spectacular and what it was you didn't
really touch it here but you touched it
a bit in your lectures it was about
integrating the shadow yep and one of
the main questions was how does one go
about that especially in the modern
world you know like really sheltered
from anything resembling that kind of
concept you know we don't engage like
the unknown we don't come into
life-or-death situations most of us must
rework is like an ambulance you know
well that's one thing you can do with
that is one thing you can do you know
well yeah you can search out experiences
that put you there that's that's that's
you know because well you can do that as
a volunteer for example I mean you can
one of the things I saw once within
Montreal I was in this outdoor mall in
Montreal on st. Hubert and saw this
great big 17 year old kid you know and
he had a mohawk and he was dressed in
leather and he with you know studs and
like he was he was he was doing the
water and Barbarian thing and he had it
really down and you know he's standing
on the corner with two pink shopping
bags hey
because look into him and I thought you
know if someone offered him the ID the
opportunity to drop those goddamn
sleeping bags or shopping bags and go
fight with Isis he'd be there in a
second yeah right because what the hell
is some monster like that doing standing
on the corner of st. Hubert Alden - pink
shopping bags so I mean so some of it is
that it you need you need to find out
where you can push where you could you
can need to find out that edge that you
can push yourself against the tree it's
going to be different for different
people
but there's there's that's the call to
adventure and heroism and there are life
and death situations everywhere around
you if you want to involve yourself in
them you know
an idiot sometimes that might be like to
put yourself together to the degree that
you can say physically or spiritually or
intellectually it could be an
intellectual battle it could be a moral
battle like the frontier is everywhere
the frontier is just the edge between
what you know and what you don't know
you want to put yourself on that damn
edge and then make yourself into
something and and you can retreat into
comfort in the modern world and I think
that is a problem you know I mean I've
noticed that it's one of the pathologies
of wealth I would say because one of the
problems with being relatively wealthy
if you're a parent is that you cannot
provide your children with necessity and
that's a big problem because they need
necessity to call them into being and
you know if you don't have a lot of
material resources and your children ask
you for something you can say no because
no is the answer it's like no you can't
do that but if you can say yes then it's
really hard to say no because then
you're just arbitrary well I don't know
it's like Kierkegaard said you know
there will come a time when we have so
much security and comfort that what
we'll want more than anything else is
part deprivation and challenge and I
think I think that's particularly what
young men want now I think that that's
partly because young women they're stuck
with that anyways because they have to
it's it's it's the necessity of living
in the world and the responsibility of
infant care in particular like that
occupies them men have to do it
voluntarily women now - because of the
birth control pill but you know that's
what thirty years ago we hardly have to
talk about that at all yes so then you
have so much
[Applause]
[Music]
hi dr. Peterson so I'm actually a Coptic
Orthodox and Egyptian so I found you're
talking a incredibly interesting I've
also taken a deep interest in the old
church fathers and as if you're talking
about Iraqis I arkin back to st.
Athanasius when the idea feels is that
you brought up last time that God became
man so that man can become like God so I
was thinking about the systems of the
hierarchies and is that an example of at
the top of the pyramid the hierarchy
sort of gets inverted or descends to the
bottom and brings it up and to the top
and that sort of an attraction to of
Christianity that sort of made
Christianity such a powerful idea what
are your thoughts on that
oh well it's certainly one of the I mean
it's certainly one of the things that we
not just Christianity a powerful idea
because one of the things that happened
this was called the democratization of
Osiris if I remember correctly and like
what happened see if I can answer this
question using this approach for sex is
that going to work
hmm I don't know if I can answer that
question that way the the part of the
attraction of Christianity but this was
something that emerged across time was
the notion that even if you were in a
lowly position that there was something
about you that was akin to the divine
and now you might say well that's just
wish fulfillment that's what Freud would
say that's what Marx would say right the
opiate of the masses tweeted yesterday
something I thought was pretty funny
which was that like religion was the
opiate of the masses but that Marxism
was the methamphetamine of the max of
the masses so so so I think the
attraction was that it it it allowed
people to recognize their intrinsic
dignity and one of the things I've been
thinking about is the juxtaposition
between Genesis 1 and Genesis 2 because
what I was in Genesis 2 is that human
beings collapse and fall right and then
were these fallen creatures that no evil
but in the beginning in Genesis 1 it's
really an optimistic story because it
says well we're the sorts of creatures
that partake in the calling forth of
being from chaos and then that's in our
essential nature and to some degree if
you juxtapose both of those it's as if
that's the entire biblical story rammed
together in the first two chapters which
is partly why we're taking so long to
get through this by the way is that to
return to Genesis 1 is the antidote to
Genesis 2 it's like to continue to act
out the doctrine that you're made in
God's image and that means that you're
you're capable of speaking good being
into existence through truth and that
that's also the antidote to the fall
which i think is actually the
fundamental narrative message of the
entire biblical structure and I also
think of Western civilization for that
matter so there's a nobility and this is
also I think Nietzsche was fundamentally
wrong in his criticism with Christianity
because he thought about it and slaves
morality
you know the Vengeance of the bottom
against the talk that's more historical
than theological
so it gives dignity it illuminates the
dignity of the human being and and
requires responsibility so it's not just
wish fulfillment it's not Freudian wish
fulfillment the Freudian theory which I
thought about a lot is not tenable in my
estimation it also doesn't account for
the existence of hell because if it's
only wish fulfillment why bother with
hell it means a lot more if you're
really going to just fulfill a wish it's
like everybody gets to go to heaven no
matter what they do you don't have hell
which was of course something absolutely
terrifying to medieval Christians and
then to plenty of people now for that
matter so it's the nobility it's the
idea of the nobility that I thinks
deeply attractive to people and that's
all there is I mean what you have to
fight against your worm-like fragile
mortal existence is the possibility of
transcending that with nobility of
speech and Act that's what you have and
who can hear that without feeling
ennoble by that now you might say well
you might shudder and say well I don't I
can't bear the responsibility it's like
well fair enough man you know I mean
that that's a reasonable criticism but
the consequence of not bearing the
responsibility is that's hell really so
thank you
[Applause]
and thank you very much beautiful um I
don't know feel familiar with the words
of nasan Talib I'm reasonably familiar
with them so I think it's sad to say
that he has he talked about the idea
that people and especially modern people
have a failure to recognize the unknown
unknowns yeah such yes right that's a
good way of thinking about it can you
move the mic up a bit so that people can
hear you a little better thanks Gary yes
um well I was wondering do you think
that that failure might might be in some
way related to the way that modern
people fail to relate to the idea of God
so in the sense that your people can't
really grapple with the notion of God I
think as much as you can give a rational
argument or you can't feel God in the
way that perhaps a more religious person
or more an older person might have felt
God do you think that that inability to
recognize the unknown unknowns might
play into that yeah well they're okay so
that seems to be related to this idea of
the absence of necessity that's
something like that is that no because I
think that I think that what you're
you're making a claim maybe tell me if
I've got it wrong that if you're
sheltered too much then it also it also
separates you from anything that's
divine I guess that might be right
because there's not enough intensity of
the experience and something like that
is that is that part of the is that part
of the issue it might be more related to
the idea of like realizing the absolute
infinite root of what you don't know
like the like the mysterium tremendum
that that kind of you know if you
believe that through statistical
analysis you can get everything under
control and you genuinely believe that
at some point you'll get it or wonder
you know yeah okay well so okay so so
well that's also I think part of the
danger of rationality that the Catholics
have been implicitly warning again
forever is that rather rational mind
tends to fall in love with its own
productions and then to worship them as
absolutes which is I think what Melville
was trying to represent by his satanic
figure in Paradise Lost I think about as
like a precursor a prophetic precursor
to the emergence of totalitarian states
in the modern world and so yeah I think
that you can believe that what you know
is sufficient to banish permanently what
you don't know and I do think that that
does paradoxically although you think
that that would make you secure it also
does destroy your relationship with with
with with with the spirit that might
help you deal with what it is that you
really don't know with the unknown
unknowns so yeah I mean we don't know to
what degree extreme experience is
necessary to bring forth extreme
experience right what do you have to be
through before you encounter a religious
revelation well people might say well
you can't because there's no such thing
it's like well don't be so sure about
that
I mean people have reported them to row
history but they don't generally occur
when your that's my favorite tropen
you're eating cheesie's and playing you
know and playing Mario Brothers right so
yeah so that's the best I can do with
that engine yes yeah
this has to be the last question all
right I'll make it quick
yeah earlier when you talked about
criminality and creativity trends in
that in men peaking at 14 it reminded me
of something you said I think it was Joe
Rogan talking about sjw's and kind of
and how they create their own chaos
talking about how adolescents have this
drive to change the world and I was
wondering if if those three the
criminality creativity drive to change
the world are linked and if so if they
manifest differently in men and women
and if they kind of come from the same
era well I think they are linked but I'm
going to concentrate more on the net
second part of your question so I'm
going to ask you two guys some think
about something so I talked to a friend
of mine the other day he's a very very
smart guy and we've been talking about
while all the sorts of things that we've
been talking about tonight for a long
time and we were talking about the
relatively relative evolutionary roles
of men and women this is speculative
obviously and and because our research
did indicate it's tentative research so
far that that the the SGS SJW sort of
equality above all else
philosophy is more prevalent among women
well it's predicted by the personality
factors that are more common among women
so agreeable this and high negative
emotion primarily agreeableness but in
addition it's also predicted by being
female and that's interesting because in
most of the personality research that
I've done and as far as I know in the
literature at you know in more broadly
speaking most of the time you can get
rid of the attitudinal differences
between men and women or at least reduce
them by controlling for personality so
if you take a feminine man and a
masculine woman then you know that the
polls reverse but that didn't seem to be
the case with political correctness and
so I've been thinking about that a lot
because well men are bailing out of the
humanities like mad and pretty much out
of the universities except for stem the
women are moving in like mad and they're
also moving into the political sphere
like math and this is new right we've
never had this happen before and we do
know no do not know what the
significance of it is it's only 50 years
old and so we were thinking about this
and so I don't know what you think about
this proposition
but imagine that that historically
speaking it's something like women were
responsible for distribution and men
were responsible for production
something like that and maybe maybe
that's only the case really in the tight
confines of the immediate family but
that doesn't matter because that's most
of the evolutionary landscape for human
beings anyways what the women does it
did was make sure that everybody got
enough okay and that seems to me to be
one of the things that's driving at
least in part the SJW demand for for
equity and equality it's like let's make
sure everybody has enough it's like both
look fair enough you know I mean you
can't you can't argue with that
but there's there's an antipathy between
that and the the reality of differential
productivity you know because people
really do differ in their productivity
so all right so to answer your question
fully I do think that the rebellious
tendency of adolescence is associated
both with that criminality spike
especially among men and with creativity
yes I think that the SJW phenomena is
different and I think it is associated
at least in part with the rise of women
to political power and and we don't know
what women are life when they have
political power because they've never
had it I mean there's been queens
obviously and that sort of thing just
being female authority figures and
females have wielded far more power
historically than feminists generally
like to admit but this is a different
thing and we don't know what a truly
female political philosophy would be
like but it might be especially if it's
not been well examined and it isn't very
sophisticated conceptually it could
easily be well let's make sure things
are distributed equally well yeah but
sorry that's that's just not going to do
you fly do you think in terms of the
rest of this JW's and you talked about
last lecture as well creating chaos when
there is none otherwise it'd be static
do you think there would be any validity
in saying that in a country like Canada
were pretty gender equal is there any
merit to thinking sjw's are trying to
create chaos even when they're arguably
is none on the mass level obviously
there's still problems why would they do
that otherwise it would be static and
that well doesn't if it wouldn't for
them so I read this
I read this quote once and I don't
remember who who said it it might have
been Robert Heinlein for crying out loud
science fiction author that springs to
mind but a problem it probably wasn't
and his the proposition was that men
tested ideas and that women tested men
and I kind of like that there's
something about that you know and now it
obviously it's an over generalization
but we also don't know to what degree
women test men Cheerilee through
provocation it's a lot because like if
you want to test someone you don't have
a like little conversation with them
like you poke the hell out of them and
you say okay like I'm going to let go
after you and see where your weak spots
are and it seems to me that this it
seems to me that in this constant
protest and use of shame and all of that
that goes along with this with this sort
of radical movement towards
egalitarianism that there's a tremendous
amount of provocation and god I'm going
to say this too even though I shouldn't
but it but we mean how I don't believe
this but I'm trying trying to figure it
out
you know I thought it was absolutely
comical when Fifty Shades of Grey came
out a not just I just thought that was
just so insanely comical that at the
same time there's this massive political
demand for like radical equality and and
and say with regards to sexual behavior
and the fastest-selling novel the world
had ever seen was S&M domination right
it's like oh well we know where the
unconscious is going with that one don't
leave and and sometimes I think like
because one of the things that I've
really tried to puzzle out and it's not
like I believe this right I'm just
telling you what I wear the edges of my
thinking of being going is that you have
this crazy alliance between the
feminists and the radical Islamist that
I just do not get it's like the
feminists it's like why they aren't
protesting non-stop about Saudi Arabia
is just completely beyond me
like I do not understand it in the least
and I wonder - I just wonder bloody well
is this is the Freudian means that is
there an attraction you know the is
there an attraction that's emerging
among the female radicals for that
totalitarian male dominance that they've
chased out of the West and I mean that's
a hell of a thing to think but I
after all I am psychoanalytically minded
and I do think things like that because
like I just can see no rational reason
for it the only other rational reason is
that well the West needs to fall and so
the enemy of my enemy is our yeah it's a
guy exactly now what is it I thought
that wrong with the enemy of enemy is my
friends yes exactly
so elements tend to vote liberal as well
yes well so that that could be the case
but I am NOT going to shake my
suspicions about this unconscious
balancing because as the demand for
egalitarianism and the eradication of
masculinity accelerates there's going to
be a longing in the unconscious for the
precise opposite for the problem of that
right the more you want you scream for
equality the more your unconscious is
going to admire dominance and so well
that's that's that's well that's how you
think if your cycle analytically minded
and you know I'm a great admirer of
Freud he knew a hell of a lot more than
people like to think and and so which is
partly why everyone still hates him even
though it's late a hundred years since
he's you know really really being around
so all right we should stop